on an ordinary day in 1991 a Young Man
known by the initials JS went on a hike
with four of his friends on the wooded
outskirts of their small town everything
seemed perfectly normal until JS began
to feel a strange sense of familiarity
like he had been in this spot before he
couldn't shake this weird feeling but
thought nothing more of it little did he
know that this was a sign of deadly
things to come several hours after first
experiencing that sense of deja vu JS
was found by the side of the road in
cuts and scratches with his friends
nowhere to be found this is the story of
SCP 939 an unforgettable monster that
you'll never remember there was no way
for JS to know that the unsettling
feeling he felt and the horrors that
followed it were the result of an
experiment conducted by the SCP
Foundation an experiment with deadly
unforeseen
consequences JS and his friends were
exposed to a substance known only as amn
c227 as part of a series of tests
performed by the SCP Foundation intended
to determine the effectiveness of this
substance as a deliberate
amnestic dealing with as many mysterious
secret creatures and objects as they do
the SCP Foundation has long needed a way
to tamper with the memories of those
exposed to the foundation's various
prisoners and test subjects and when the
foundation discovered amn c227 it seemed
like it might be perfect for this
purpose so where did amn c227 come from
over a year before the incident with JS
and his friends the SCP Foundation
captured SCP 939 SCP 939 is a species of
endothermic predators that live and hunt
in packs they are designated keter class
and regarded as highly dangerous and
hostile to human life native to caves
they have no eyes translucent red skin
and stand at an average of 2.2 M tall
with an average weight of 250 kg they
have four limbs each ending in three
fingered Claws and a fourth opposable
digit resembling a thumb in addition to
their sharp claws their mouths are
filled with red fang-like teeth that
reach up to 6 cm in length in place of
their absent eyes they have light
sensitive spots running along their
backs which are covered in spines
believed to detect changes in air
pressure and flow in addition to their
many other terrifying attributes the
internal anatomy of scp-939 poses a
biological mystery these creatures have
no circulatory system and no digestive
tract that's right in spite of being
Predators seemingly acting on a need to
feed they have no stomach instead when
they eat their food builds up in their
respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function and then it is
regurgitated in spite of being a
creature that should not under any
logical conditions be able to live SCP
939 continues to persist and is even
capable of giving birth to live young
after a gestation period of 12 months
the SCP Foundation was able to study a
litter of these young that were born in
captivity in September of
1992 though the creatures remain just as
much of a scientific mystery as they
were upon first discovery everything
about them seems to defy the logic of
the natural world which to be fair is
really nothing new for the foundation
the respiratory system of SCP 939 was
found to Exhale small traces of an
airborne amnestic substance given the
name amnc 227 this compound blocks the
formation of memories for the duration
of exposure to it plus a 30-minute
period following the exposure give or
take a few minutes it is colorless
odorless tasteless and completely
undetectable in the bloodstream after
only 60 Minutes amn c227 was approved
for use as a Class C amnestic by the SCP
Foundation in 1990 following some
initial tests however after one
particular incident involving a young
man and his friends the official use of
amnc c227 was suspended JS and three of
his four friends were previously given a
dose of amn c227 though the details of
why they were given the amnestic has
since been stricken from the record
several months after being exposed to
amn c227 JS and his friends went out on
their ill-fated hiking trip while hiking
JS was suddenly overcome with the sense
of deja vu when he mentioned it to his
friends three of them agreed that they
had felt it too one of the group another
young man who had not been exposed to
amn c227 was uncomfortable and decided
to go home JS and the remaining three
members of the group made the choice to
stay in the woods and try to determine
what was triggering the unusual feeling
of familiarity as they got closer and
closer to a large cave near the hiking
trail the sense of having been there
before grew stronger and stronger armed
with only one flashlight and a foolish
curiosity the four went inside the cave
they made their way deeper and deeper
and deeper into the darkness not knowing
KN why they felt this way or what they
might find inside none of the group
could explain just what felt so familiar
only that the further they made their
way into the cave the more pronounced
the feeling became it was getting late
and they knew they should have been
afraid to venture so deep into a cave
with only one light source and no
knowledge of what lay inside but still
they pressed on one of the group
remarked that they should turn back but
the others refused to listen they wanted
to know what they were getting close to
what was drawing them deeper and deeper
into the cave unfortunately for them
they would get their answer in the heart
of the cave was a pack of SCP 939
waiting patiently for their prey to
wander into their domain there are no
witnesses to account for what exactly
happened to JS and his companions but we
can reasonably piece the events together
from what happened after once the
friends reached the heart of the Cave
the creatures were on them in seconds
raking them with their sharp claws and
biting with their fangs SCP 939 are
larger and stronger than most people so
it was probably not not much of a fight
however while his friends were being
devoured JS was somehow able to scramble
out of the cave and make his way into
the woods in search of help under the
influence of the am c227 that had built
up in the cave from the presence of the
pack of
scp-939 JS lost a large portion of his
memory of the event he found himself on
the side of the highway late at night
seriously injured and his clothes ripped
an officer found him there and asked him
to stay still and remain calm until an
ambulance could arrive JS was still in a
panic and attempted to run away from the
officer begging to be released so that
he could get away he babbled incon about
the color red screaming over and over
again about the red though impr prompted
he could not explain what the red he was
screaming about referred to his friends
were not with him just as the officer
managed to calm JS the ambulance arrived
its flashing red light sent him into
another frenzy and he attempted to
escape custody claiming that the red
lights were going to get him the
official police report described JS as
perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen that he was just
having a bad trip but the SCP Foundation
knew better the foundation conducted an
interview with JS about his experience
and determined that SCP 939 was
certainly involved as part of their
cover up effort they strongly implicated
JS in The Disappearance and the death of
his friends he was convicted of
manslaughter though the bodies of his
friends were never found it is rumored
that the SCP Foundation hired him on a
prison work release program and that he
now works as a member of the janitorial
staff at one of the foundation's
facilities this incident led to the
suspension of the use of amn c227 as it
revealed some vital and disturbing
information about the compound side
effects after the exposure to amn c227 a
person who found themselves exposed to
it again would experience a sense of
familiarity and felt compelled to
investigate the source of this feeling
essentially anyone treated with amn c227
are not made aware of the existence and
danger of SCP 939 would become a perfect
victim primed to be attracted to dens of
SCP 939 it is likely that this side
effect is not a coincidence but rather a
deliberate hunting tactic designed to
attract prey that had somehow managed to
escape with no memory of their attack at
the hands of SCP 939 this previous
intended prey would find themselves
drawn to the same Den or even a new one
not knowing that they were walking back
into near certain death while the SCP
Foundation suspended the use of amn c227
as a Class C amnestic they did recruit a
team of SCP field operatives to take
advantage of this side effect this team
of operatives were deliberately
administered a dose of amn c227 and
briefed on its effects as well as the
dangers of following the feeling of deja
vu should it surface in the field these
infected officers were essentially used
as blood hounds relying on any sense of
unusual familiarity to sniff out new
dens of SCP 939 so they could be
captured and contain ained by the
foundation as far as we know this
operation is still ongoing today however
now that the foundation has a sufficient
number of specimens to study additional
dens of scp-939 that are discovered are
ordered to be immediately destroyed as
for the SCP 939 still in captivity they
are contained in environmentally
regulated and negatively pressured cells
with walls of reinforced concrete the
doors to the cells are airtight to
prevent the leakage of any amn
c227 and any Personnel that interact
with one of the creatures is required to
wear level C Hazmat gear to avoid
exposure and follow decontamination
procedures upon exiting the cell all SCP
939 have subdermal tracking devices
implanted to find them in the event of
Escape only one SCP 939 has given birth
in the time that the creatures have been
in captivity strangely scp-939 young
look indistinguishable from Human
infants and change their physical
appearance at some yet unknown Point as
they age if any more offspring are
produced they will immediately be
separated from the parent and studied
all that we know is that they are found
in caves in the woods outside of a small
town it could be any Town even yours so
if you're ever out hiking and struck
with a sudden feeling of deja vu don't
investigate don't get curious just go
home it might just save your life it was
July of 2004 and Bill Murray was
enjoying the peak of an an extremely
successful career not only had the
iconic actors starred in some of the
most beloved comedies of the 20th
century including Ghostbusters in
Groundhog Day he'd voiced the main
character of the recently released
live-action Garfield movie it' been a
financial success but it was a critical
flop not that this bothered Bill he was
happy with the performance and the
paycheck what he wouldn't be quite as
happy about was the horrifying encounter
he was about to have with SCP
3166 on July 8th bill was enjoying a
cold drink on the porch of his luxurious
Beverly Hills Home the sky was beginning
to darken as the sun set in the west it
was a blissful evening his wife Jennifer
was inside watching TV nothing seemed
particularly out of the ordinary until
he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance it was almost too fast to
register this large orange shaped
darting past the corner of his eye for a
second he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped Tiger but
it was gone too fast to really tell Bill
finished his drink and headed inside he
had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics one review
stated no one can accuse Garfield the
movie of infidelity to its source it
Faithfully conveys the finality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film
without energy and without Spirit he put
the paper down and ate his breakfast a
few blows to the ego were worth it for
the paydays that came with big budget
family films just then his wife came to
him with a strange question were you
walking around downstairs in the middle
of the night no he hadn't he'd been
sleeping like a baby why did she ask
well Jennifer said I heard some rustling
downstairs last night it sounded like
something big he hadn't heard anything
though and told her it was probably just
Her Imagination he put it out of his
mind and continued about his day he
decided he would keep his eyes peeled
for that orange blur again though Bill
didn't see anything peculiar the rest of
the morning and went to a local cafe for
lunch he ordered a coffee and a cream
cheese bagel then made a quick trip to
the bathroom while his food was prepared
when Bill returned to his table though
there was something strange instead of a
bagel there was a large heaping of
lasagna on the table what was going on
this Cafe didn't even serve lasagna Bill
knew something was terribly wrong things
only got stranger when bill came home to
find a small tuft of orange fur snagged
on the frame of his front door and it
wasn't synthetic fur like you'd see on
plush toys or stuffed animals no this
was real animal fur maybe someone was
just goofing off or trying to play some
weird prank on him but it didn't feel
like it deep down Bill Murray knew that
he was engrav danger whoever or whatever
was behind this it wanted to hurt hurt
him that night his worst fears were
realized Bill's wife had left town for
the week and he was headed to the
kitchen in the middle of the night for a
glass of water when he saw something a
huge figure moving up against the glass
door leading to his backyard the thing
was huge nearly 7 ft tall with a bloated
fur covered misshapen body that was
pressed up against the door its fur was
bright garish orange a cartoon orange
strangest of all though was the the
sound it was making it sounded like it
was purring Bill backed away from the
door and then ran back to his room to
hide the whole night he sat cowering as
he heard scratching against the walls
like something was trying to get in he
was terrified and too scared to do
anything even move finally as morning
broke the noises seemed to stop Bill had
to do something he couldn't let this
nightmare go on another night what if
things got worse what if that thing
managed to get inside he called the
local police and when they arrived he
explained the incredibly strange
situation as best he could he told them
he was being stalked by some kind of
huge cat or at least someone dressed
like a huge cat also there was lasagna
involved the officers interviewing him
could barely contain their laughter as
he told them his story a giant orange
cat perhaps one of them theorized he
angered some kind of obsessive Garfield
fam through his involvement in the
liveaction movie after all the original
comic had been running for years and had
been extremely popular who knows what
kind of nut jobs were obsessed with
seeing only a faithful adaptation of the
source material as the officers departed
bill was confident that they weren't
taking him seriously he couldn't rely on
any of them for protection thankfully
from a multi-decade movie career he had
plenty of disposable income and decided
to hire a private security team to
protect him while he looked into this
mystery he had two trained bodyguards
positioned around his home at all times
for the next month they were armed and
given the cryptic orders to fire on
anything orange meanwhile Bill began to
Fall Down A Garfield Rabbit Hole he felt
strangely compelled to research all the
Garfield media he could find as though
the answer to his terrifying situation
was somehow hidden between the lines
Bill explored the entire backlog of
thousands of comic strips he read the
books and interviews with Jim Davis he
watched the cartoons and straight to DVD
animated movies ironically for a guy
who'd recently portrayed the lasagna
loving orange cat Bill had never felt
quite so immersed in the character
before he found the strange Pathos in
the routine of Garfield and his friends
one particular comic really piqued his
interest though originally published in
October of 1989 the comic began with
Garfield being woken up by a strange
chill an almost Eerie sensation the
character observed aloud that he didn't
feel like he was in his own home he
explored his little home first trying to
find his owner JN or his housemate and
sometimes Nemesis OD but found nothing
as Garfield remarked on feeling alone a
purple speech box delivered the Sinister
message you have no idea how alone you
are
Garfield he then finds that his home
looks like it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient Garfield slowly comes to a
horrifying Revelation everyone really is
gone and his adventures and friends now
exist only in his imagination he's
trapped in a prison of his own creation
trying to Stave off his endless
loneliness in denial about the reality
of his situation the comic ended with a
quote directly from Jim Davis himself
saying an imagination is a powerful tool
it can tint memories of the past shade
perceptions of the present or paint a
future so vivid that it can entice or
terrify all depending upon how we
conduct ourselves today as he read those
words Bill Murray felt a chill down his
spine why had he wanted to get involved
in the Garfield movie in the first place
what had he gotten himself into before
he could slip any deeper into his own
mind Bill heard a faint choked scream
downstairs he felt his breath catch in
his throat he was terrified but needed
to see what was happening he carefully
and quietly began to creep down the
stairs at the bottom he poked his head
around a corner and that's when he saw a
member of his security detail lying dead
on the floor his face was Blue from
asphixiation his mouth was stuffed with
lasagna it looked like he had been
force-fed to
death Bill wanted to scream but he
couldn't or maybe knew he shouldn't just
then he heard a soft meaty thumping
noise coming from the nearby living room
he didn't know why but he felt compelled
to approach as if by forces Beyond his
control he made his way to the living
room and when he'd got there he saw
where the noise was coming from Bill's
jaw dropped in pure horror there was the
other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure who was a grotesquely huge
creature wearing what looked to be a
kind of crude Garfield outfit made of
sewn together cat pounds it stank of
pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held a golden trophy which it was
using to pound the SEC security guard's
head into mush while making quiet
catlike purring noises the creature
suddenly stopped and looked up locking
eyes with Bill the fear of death came
over him he froze as the giant freakish
Garfield stepped over Donnie's corpse
and began to come towards him bill
turned and ran but Garfield was gaining
on him before he could make it to the
front door the creature knocked him over
he was laid out on the ground looking up
at it as it reached into its own body
cavity and began to pull out handfuls of
lasagna he was about to shove a wad of
the horrible decaying pasta into Bill's
mouth when suddenly a ding Was Heard and
the creature stopped it looked up as if
sniffing the air and then suddenly
turned and lumbered towards the
kitchen Bill watched as the Garfield
monster entered the kitchen where
somehow there was a steaming hot fresh
lasagna sitting in the open oven the
creature had sensed the presence of
external lasagna and felt the compulsion
to integrate it into its body grabbing
fistfuls and shoving it into
itself just then a group of highly
trained SCP Foundation Personnel burst
into the room and subdued the creature
it had been an ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches and the report of
a 7ft tall comic book cat terrorizing a
Hollywood actor was definitely worth
looking into the monster that had almost
taken Bill Murray's life was SCP 31
66 a deadly pataphysical being that
tends to manifest around people somehow
involved in the Garfield intellectual
property it appears whenever the public
perception of Garfield falls out of
favor and because Bill had starred in
the critically paned Garfield movie he
was currently at the very top of SCP
3166 is Hit List thankfully he managed
to survive his terrifying Oreal and was
administered amnestics by Foundation
Personnel so that he could return to his
normal life this frightening and
mysterious creature has been around
since 1989 appearing after the
publication of The Haunting Garfield
comic that Bill had read that very night
it appeared in the office of United
media who were the Publishers of the
Garfield comic strip at the time and
began wrecking Havoc since then the
creatures manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result
the foundation has spent years as the
funding source behind all Garfield media
imp planting hypnotic mimetics into the
comic strips to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base the fur is
indeed real organic cat fur albeit an
unnaturally orange color and instead of
organs the creature is filled with
lasagna worst of all though is that
testing has revealed that the meat in
the lasagna is genetically identical to
the Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim
Davis how did this thing come into
existence perhaps it was Jim's sheer
force force of imagination that dragged
it into being as he himself said an
imagination is a powerful tool all in
all it's lucky that Bill Murray was able
to survive his encounter and return to
his normal life well as normal as life
can be for Bill Murray and if you see
Bill Murray don't bother asking him
about SCP
3166 the amnestics were quite effective
and just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you one of the
primary aims of the SCP Foundation is to
contain the anomalies that they discover
secure contain protect is their mission
statement after all however there are
some forces so unknowable and malevolent
that there is no way to truly contain
them SCP 4205 is one such Force very
little is known about SCP
425 even compared to other scps many of
which are mysterious by their very
nature
we do not know what it is we do not know
what it wants and we do not have any
meaningful way to stop it the best that
can be done to protect yourself from it
is to implement the few known
preventative measures available and pray
that it doesn't set its sites on you the
little information that exists on SCP
4205 was recorded by Wayde dallat a
former Junior researcher at the
foundation he wrote the initial report
on SCP 4205 on a computer Terminal 4
though his work was highly valuable and
provided many previously unknown
insights about the nature of the SCP
sadly his knowledge could not save him
the official entry on SCP 4205 was his
final act before his death on December
11th
1992 before we get deeper into that
entry and Wade's final day on Earth it's
important to understand what SC SCP 4205
is or at least understand the little we
know about what it is is 4205 is a ker
class SCP meaning that it's incredibly
difficult or complicated to contain it
also shows extreme hostility toward all
life it is described as an amber colored
pair of humanlike eyes with the ability
to appear spontaneously in Windows
mirrors or any other glass or glass-like
Surface one of the reasons so little is
known about these eyes is that anyone
who sees them dies within seconds much
like the mythical basilisk the Gaze of
SCP 4205 is deadly and inescapable the
eyes only seem to appear to people who
are alone in a room and never in places
where there's more than one person but
aside from that there is no way to
predict where the eyes will appear since
it is unknown if the eyes are part of a
corporeal body or even present on this
plane of reality there is no way to
contain them or stop them from killing
this brings us to that fateful day
December 11th
1992 the day that the SCP Foundation
would finally be given some tangible
information on the mysterious Amber eyes
at the cost of one of their researchers
lives Wade dallat a young man fresh out
of his university studies was brought on
board as a junior researcher by Dr Mark
fory a senior researcher Dr fory
recruited Wade after giving a guest
lecture at his university and being
impressed by Wade's Keen observational
skills thirst for knowledge of the unex
and determination to understand that
which seemed to defy explanation after
Wade graduated he was recruited by Dr
foresight and given the position of
Junior researcher at the SCP Foundation
where he assisted Dr foresy now a site
supervisor in his research after several
months of working under Dr foresight
with minimal responsibilities Wade was
finally given the opportunity to write
his first SCP report on SCP
4205 following some initial initial
documented appearances of 4205 Dr
forsite approved further research into
the anomaly with Wade appointed as the
lead researcher on the subject according
to Wade's entry he was responsible for
the discovery of SCP 4205 when he
spotted the anomaly in a window the
later reviews of security footage
determined that he was not the first
person to observe the eyes he did claim
to be the first to observe them and live
to tell the Tale in his writing on the
subject Wade is puzzled by the fact that
he survived vied his encounter with SCP
4205 and wonders what could have set him
apart from the others that fell victim
to its gaze he found himself frustrated
as he documented SCP
4205 his rough drafts of reports
dissolving into angry rants about his
own incompetence Wayne had difficulty
adjusting to his new responsibilities
especially with the added element of his
assigned subject's mysterious and
volatile nature in between his reports
on SCP 4205 its previous appearances and
and its effects on its victims he wrote
letters to his father desperate for
reassurance that he was not messing
everything up letters that would sadly
go unsent in this coverage of SCP 4205
Wade made note of a troubling
reoccurring element in each victim's
death when medical professionals
attempted to revive the victims it was
always noted that their brain activity
stopped much more quickly than in cases
of death by natural causes when examined
all aspects of the body aside from the
brain were completely unharmed the brain
however showed massive nerve damage in
the amydala hippocampus medial temporal
lobe and occipital lobe the appearance
of this brain trauma had been compared
to the effects of electrical shock or a
severe head injury in addition to wade
six other people on record encountered
SCP
4205 every encounter ended the same way
with sudden brain death and severe nerve
damage immediately after viewing the
eyes in a reflective surface the first
encounter occurred on January 5th 1990
when deputy liaz GA viewed the eyes in a
reflective glass oneway window security
tape reveals that the eyes appeared in
the Window 8 minutes before the deputy
leoon spotted them as soon as he did he
fell from his chair and immediately died
though the specifics varied from case to
case the end result of every encounter
was the same with none surviving long
enough to relate what they had
experienced every encounter except Wades
as he continued his documentation of SCP
4205 Wade's mental state quickly began
to deteriorate the process of his mind
coming apart and his thoughts giving way
to confusion fear and anger at his own
Survival is documented in his reports on
the SCP he agonized over the questions
of why he was able to survive gazing
into the eyes of SCP
4205 when so many others had not the
question consumed him until he was
unable to eat sleep or do anything but
obsess over the SCP he was tasked with
researching as he became more agit
itated he began to write about the eyes
appearing to him again on one occurrence
he attempted to touch them and described
the sensation like touching a balloon to
your arm after it had been charged with
static electricity he continued to
report seeing the eyes the worse was
when trying to sleep during which he was
overtaken by violent sleep paralysis and
plagued with visions of the Amber eyes
the only comfort Wade seemed to find was
in memories of his loved ones he wrote
about his mother and his father even as
their memories grew foggier to him he
also mentioned a man by the name of
Theodore Quail who he claimed was a
researcher at the foundation later
factchecking determined that this was
not the case and that Quail must have
been someone from Wade's past he wrote
about quail wistfully mournfully with
words of love and loss tormented by the
sense that he was losing his grip on
reality and everything he once held dear
as Wade descended deeper into a hell
inside his own mind he continued to mull
over the questions of SCP 4205
was there more to it than what was
visible did it have a body why had he
survived the encounter with it and what
did it want from him he decided that
those who had perished immediately were
the lucky ones they had escaped the
torture that had overtaken his life the
eyes were everywhere now watching him
even as he attempted to unlock their
secrets on a foundation computer he
spoke to the eyes at one point but
refused to write down what they said to
him his last entry his last thought was
a plea for Theodore qu
Embrace there is no more written about
the research or about the eyes only a
simple desperate need for a comfort that
is long lost now is the part of our
story where Terror meets tragedy
contrary to what Wade thought and what
was recorded in his final computer
entries he did not survive his brief
brush with SCP
4205 the truth is that he spotted the
Amber eyes in the glass above his
terminal monitor while recording the
entry and died seconds later though his
death was Swift it felt agonizingly slow
as revealed by his descent into panic
and paranoia recorded in his writings
the entry is recorded as a result of the
connection weighed in the computer his
physical contact with it at the moment
of exposure to SCP 4205 anomalous
effects allowing the terminal to Archive
his final thoughts before he succumbed
to the deadly nature of the eyes the
entries were never physically typed but
rather jumped from his dying mind into
the main frame his entries The Echoes of
a Dying mind offer a glimpse into the
way that SCP 4205 kills its victims in
the seconds leading up to death the
Amber eyes fast forward a person's mind
feeding on the electrical impulses that
it gives off as it speeds through what
seems to be days of fear and of a
loosening grip on reality the death may
be swift but the suffering is long Wade
left the foundation with a digital
fingerprint an echo of the person he was
at his core in addition to his
experiences with SCP 4205 itself Wade
spent his final moments terrified for
his life dreaming of a father that he
missed and a long lost love from his
college days his sacrifice must not be
forgotten because no one ever survives
an encounter with SCP
4205 his documented final moments are
the only firsthand account in existence
Junior researcher way dollits gave us a
gift in death he allowed the SCP
Foundation a glimpse into the true
horror of the Amber eyes and a reminder
of what they are capable of stealing
from us so be careful of Windows mirrors
screens and all reflective surfaces when
you look into them you never know what
you might see looking back it goes
without saying that the SCP Foundation
archives are filled with some terrifying
monsters even the deadliest creatures
can in theory be be defeated or at least
soundly avoided after all they're just
flesh and blood or in some cases metal
or concrete but what if reality as you
know it one day just broke or worse you
were transported to a reality so
frightening and alien to our own that
death seemed like the only Escape but
you couldn't even give yourself that
this brings us to today's topic the
terrifying alternate reality of SCP
3001 the foundation is no stranger to
freaky alternate Dimensions but what was
experienced by joint lead researcher Dr
Robert Scranton at site 120 is a truly
unique nightmare co-managed by his wife
Dr Anna Lang site 120 is a facility
largely designated for Research into
scps with dangerous reality warping
capabilities in order to mitigate future
containment breaches reality warpers are
among some of the more perplexing and
dangerous scps from the pocket Dimension
creating SCP 106 to the SCP creating Dr
Wonder tainment and everything in
between Scranton and Lang's goal to
further study such entities was an
admirable one if a little over ambitious
and on January 2nd 2000 during the
testing of a new technology created by
the foundation's leading power couple
disaster finally struck Scranton and
Lang had already been the brains behind
one of the foundation's most valuable
tools in the fight against reality
bending scps the Scranton reality
anchors their followup the langing
Scranton stable ier or LSS likely would
have been an even more advanced variant
of their earlier invention and should
have been a huge success for the team
but things didn't turn out that way Dr
Scranton and several other researchers
were gathered in reality lab a
performing routine tests on the LSS
prototypes while other technicians ran
Diagnostics tests Scranton stood at the
control panel the blinking red light
above the console confirming that
everything was going according to plan
but as anyone who's Fallen victim to one
of the foundation's many anomal IES will
tell you just because you've done
everything correctly doesn't mean you're
safe Scranton began operating the
machine not knowing that something was
rumbling up towards him from below
without warning a sudden unexpected
burst of seismic activity rocked the
entire base researchers grabbed on to
whatever was closest as the world shook
around them in his Panic Dr Scranton
clung to the LSS control panel as the
seismic blast fried the circuits and
kicked it into
overdrive there was a blast of
magnificent blinding light and when the
rumbling stopped Not only was the doctor
gone he had been erased from reality as
we know it the earthquake had caused a
deadly malfunction in the machine meant
to stabilize reality and instead tore a
rift in it dragging the unfortunate
doctor and the control panel into
Oblivion his wife Dr Lang and the many
researchers who idolized him were
devastated by his unexpected demise at
the hand of what should have been his
crowning achievement the one silver
lining was that this reality ripping
event had had almost definitely
eliminated the doctor quickly and
painlessly as far as the foundation and
his loved ones were concerned Scranton's
death had been immediate and complete a
luxury afforded to few Foundation
employees who die anomalous deaths but
sadly that isn't how Dr Scranton Story
or the story of SCP
3001 ends no this is where it all begins
how do we know all this in the hellish
new place where Scranton had been
transported the control panel from the
LSS that he'd been clinging to for dear
life had been transported with him and
continued to record audio data from this
anomalous location not that do Scranton
realized it not at first anyway as far
as he knew he'd suddenly been
transported into a pitch black location
no sites no sounds no sense true
nothingness at first the doctor was
confused one second he was testing out
his new technology and the next he was
quite literally nowhere in spite of his
current situation the doctor was still
an intelligent and rational man he took
a moment to compose himself hoping that
in time his eyes would adjust to the new
Darkness around him but that moment
never came the darkness remained
perfectly absolute much like the
darkness in another reality defying SCP
the deadly endless staircase known as
SCP 087 the dark seemed thick almost
like you could touch it the doctor not
wanting to give himself to Despair and
die in this impossible place and with no
other options seemingly available
began walking either he'd find his way
out or the foundation would find him no
need to panic it may have altered the
doctor's temperament if he knew that the
foundation already assumed he was dead
and that no search party was going to
come looking for him still logic
dictates that if a person walks for long
enough they're bound to find something
the problem Scranton was about to face
was that SCP 3001 doesn't run by any
kind of conventional logic he walked and
walked and walked but he didn't seem to
get any any nearer to or farther from
anything but how could he even know
after all in total darkness there aren't
any landmarks to assist in navigation
the doctor walked and paced and screamed
for days on end but he made no progress
he was alone in an empty world he had no
choice though so he kept walking and
walking and walking for 11 days during
that time he felt his hunger and thirst
grow he was in terrible pain from a of
starvation and dehydration but the
release of death didn't seem to come for
him he was going to have to learn the
rules of this new place the hard way and
it grimly dawned on Dr Scranton that
dying in this place might not even be
the worst possible outcome he paced and
repeated facts to himself hoping to
ground himself in the moment and avoid
the Panic that could so easily set in
name Robert Scranton age 39 birthday
September 19th 1961 favorite color blue
favorite song Living on a Prayer wife
Anna little by little the words seemed
to turn to nonsense in his mouth as the
terror grew just as he felt like he was
about to lose his mind he noticed
something a small Oasis in the endless
darkness of SCP
3001 the glowing red light on the LSS
control panel where had it come from and
how was it still recording the doctor
had no idea but he was grateful for any
kind of familiarity in the strange
Darkness around him perhaps the LSS
could be the key to saving him or at
least figuring out what on Earth was
going on here whatever the case there
was no denying that having the panel
here was better than nothing at least
when it was found if it was ever found
then people would know what had happened
to him as the days passed and he
continued to mysteriously survive Dr
Scranton induced that one didn't need
food or water to survive continually in
SCP
3001 the location had an anomalous
effect on its inhabitants
as the days passed and turned to weeks
of wandering in the darkness Dr Scranton
further deduced that he was no longer in
his home Dimension this was an entirely
separate pocket Dimension much like the
one possessed by SCP 106 but featureless
a perfect self-contained void now dimly
illuminated by the red light of the
panel Dr Scranton explored further into
the void around him he traveled for
months on end the pain of his
deficiencies growing by the day but
found was getting nowhere All Things
Considered he wasn't even sure he was
moving or whether reality and darkness
were swirling around him like a thick
liquid rather than walking on a single
flat surface he was moving in all
directions across a three-dimensional
plane the SpaceTime Continuum appeared
to be entirely broken here where
movement is more defined by the
conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning Dr
Scranton knew that this place broke
every single one of Kel's laws of
reality parameters and from as years
working with a plethora of reality
warpers in site 120 he had a theory for
why this pocket Dimension was so strange
it had an extraordinarily weak Hume
field before we get back to Dr
Scranton's semi- living nightmare we
need a quick primer on Hume Theory and
why having a weak Hume field is such a
problem a Hume is a unit of measurement
for the strength and amount of reality
in a given location or being in an area
with an incredibly low Hume field
relative to our world such as SCP 3001
Universe breaches and anomalous
incidents rise significantly at the time
of his being trapped there SCP 31 had
the lowest number of Humes in any
recorded environment making it a
phenomenally anomalous Zone it was for
this reason that starvation and
dehydration never took hold of him
despite causing him great pain and the
worst by far was Yet to Come Dr Scranton
wasn't trapped in this dimension for
weeks or even months he was trapped in
the darkness for years and it took a
nightmarish toll on his body and mind
the small flashing red light on his his
LSS control panel became his only friend
and as the years Drew on he would hold
entire conversations with his only
source of Illumination he knew that his
days were numbered if he didn't escape
the dimension within around 3 years the
Hume field would diffuse further and he
would be left in a truly horrific state
but based on how little Headway he made
in the time he'd been there he didn't
feel optimistic he kept speaking into
the recorder if only to break the
silence and prevent him from going
completely insane but even that would
only hold it off for so long alone and
talking to himself endlessly in the
darkness Dr Scranton could feel his mind
slipping as the confines of the pocket
Dimension constricted and his body began
to change the low Hume field slowly
diffused his physical matter destroying
the physical Integrity of his body but
never being merciful enough to actually
let him die in this haunting audio logs
the doctor described his hands as
diffusing and thinning out like spider
webs over time there was less and less
of him and what was left wasn't entirely
human as Scranton's Hume level lowered
to equalize with that of SCP 3001 the
lines between his body and the LSS
control console began to blur in a
Twisted marriage of warped flesh and
machine the Lang Granton stabilizer was
anything but stable before his mind and
body became something else entirely the
doctor still had the presence of mind to
finally realize how he'd come to be in
this terrible place the LSS had opened a
wormhole known as a Class C broken entry
into a paradoxical pocket Dimension
between layers of reality and taken him
through it he'd slipped through a crack
in reality into absolute darkness and
now he was stuck with a fate far worse
than death how do we know any of this
much like the event in the first place
it's a total accident testing Superior
reality bending technology almost 6
years after The Disappearance caused the
sudden Return of the missing LSS to site
120's reality Labs the only trace of Dr
Scranton that it brought back with it
was the blood and viscera that coated
the console much to the abject horror of
his still grieving wife Dr Anna Lang to
this day Dr Scranton formerly one of the
foundation's brightest Minds remains
trapped in the nightmare of SCP 3001 his
current condition whether the doctor is
still alive after 20 years of being
warped by the low Hume field of 301's
darkened confines is still unknown but
for the doctor's own sake we hope he's
been dead for quite some time because
few things on earth are as horrifying as
the alternative warning this site is for
SCP personnel with 05 approval access
Beyond this point for those with
standard level four security is
prohibited and may result in termination
of foundation employment unauthorized
visitors who survived the mimic kill
agent are detained and interrogated
under truth exacting mtic agents Dr
Herman Wright was used to high security
protocols he had been working with the
SCP Foundation for several years and had
dealt with specimens both terrifying and
Val valuable but something about this
site was different the security was
tighter than he'd ever seen and it all
seemed a bit too much for what looked
like a run-of-the-mill warehouse in
Alexandria Egypt the street seemed
normal it was surrounded by businesses
selling food and clothes and none of the
locals seemed to give a Second Glance
but as soon as he was approved for
Access and entered the warehouse it was
a very different story he looked into
the Cognito Hazard testing screen
designed to cause psychic damage to
anyone who hadn't been inoculated by the
foundation and entered the large bunker
automated guns lined the walls he could
see the outlines of trap doors below him
and he was pretty sure the whole place
was rigged to blow if a large scale
assault hit the foundation was taking no
chance with whatever they had found in
Egypt what could they be keeping locked
up below as Dr Wright walked through the
long tunnel leading to the staircase he
could see a series of rules marked on
the wall no open Flames allowed within
SC CP 401 no firearms or bladed weapons
allowed within SCP 401 all riding
utensils brought into SCP 401 must be
approved by a majority of the 05 Council
violating these conditions could cause a
CK class restructuring scenario or an XK
Class end of the world scenario Dr wri's
mind raised as he entered the massive
antichamber and descended the staircase
but he wasn't prepared for what he saw
it was a library
the biggest library he had ever seen
with bookcases stretched as far as the
eye could see the library was Far bigger
than the warehouse look from the outside
and Dr Wright assumed it must be a
disguise built on top of the much bigger
older facility that had been discovered
by the foundation it wouldn't be the
first time the foundation found
something that didn't conform to the
laws of ukian geometry SCP locations
often played by their own rules as Dr
Wright exited the staircase and walked
up to the the first bookcase he could
swear he heard rustling sounds among the
shelves was something moving he hadn't
seen anyone walking the aisles when he
descended the staircase and he was
pretty sure he was alone here wasn't he
making things stranger a quick look at
the bookcase didn't show any books he
was familiar with none had standard
titles in fact they all seemed to follow
a simple format each title a different
individual person all books look the
exact same
same binding same thickness same number
of pages was this some sort of SCP
reference library suddenly a hand
slapped down on Dr W's shoulder and his
heart nearly jumped out of his chest he
turned to see a gray-haired man in an
SCP lab code extending a hand to him Dr
whan Henri Chief scientist in charge of
testing at SCP
401 you must be Dr Wright he didn't give
Dr Wright a chance to respond Dr henrix
didn't seem like the the kind of man to
be very interested in what others had to
say yes yes about time the foundation
sent me a new research assistant I
suppose you have a lot of questions Dr
Wright was supposed to be a researcher
not an assistant he didn't suppose it
would do any good to point that out when
Dr Wright tried to question what it was
that he'd be researching Dr Henrik told
him that it would be easier to show than
explain with that he motioned Dr Wright
to a nearby table where one of the
countless identical books on the shelves
was with waiting he nodded at the book
prompting the younger doctor to turn it
over and read the title he couldn't
believe what he saw there on the front
of the book was his name Herman Wright
Dr Wright looked at his colleague in
confusion and Dr henrik's motion for him
to take a look it was written in a
language that he had never seen before
but was somehow instantly recognizable
and understandable and the book really
was about him every detail of his life
had been written down in this volume
starting with his birth containing
details that no one but he knew his
whole life story was here from his
childhood to his education to his
eventual recruitment by the SCP
Foundation but the book wasn't completed
the last line that had been written
described his entry into the secured
confines of SCP 401 that very day Dr
Henrik had a mad glint in his eye are
you starting to understand one for each
of us every person who has ever lived
roughly 120 billion people since the
dawn of man their lives all written down
in these books every time someone is
born their book appears in this library
and their story gets written as it
happens the foundation has been
monitoring this site since the 1800s but
it's been operating much longer than
that since the dawn of recorded history
Dr henrik's PTO to write another book it
was simply titled the Hunter and it
chronicled the life of a prehist
historic man who spent his days
searching for Wild game he lived 23
violent monotonous years before his
story ended abruptly when the
saber-tooth tiger decided it was
interested in the same Mammoth he was
hunting this must have been one of the
oldest books in the library a book for
every person on Earth Dr R could only
imagine what the scale of this massive
Library must be Dr Henrik explained that
mapping the library was a huge challenge
before producing a map from his pocket
and laying it out on on the desk you're
at base camp this is where new births
generate on the shelves along with books
pertaining to the first humans if you
want to drag down specific books you'll
need to know where you're going we've
established base camps around the
library to Mark significant errors in
human history with notable books at each
Camp you'll find generators supplies and
beacons to light your way if you're
going back far enough you could be
traveling for days or even weeks Dr
Wright was fascinated by this bizarre
location containing the sum total of
Human Experience within its massively
expanding walls but there was one thing
he couldn't figure out just why was this
seemingly harmless location featuring
constantly changing books the most
securely guarded SCP he had ever
encountered Dr Henrik knew he was
referring to the extensive rules he had
must have seen as he entered the other
doctor reached into his pocket and said
let's just say that around here the pen
is mightier than the sword he pressed
the pen into Dr W's hand and flipped
open the back page of his book it was
blank the rest of his story waiting to
be written watch something you've always
wanted in your life Dr Wright think
literally why not put it in your book or
remove something you've always wanted
gone slowly Dr W thought back to his
teenage years and recalled an injury
that he suffered in a mugging that
damaged his leg and left him with a limp
he nervously used the pen to scribble
out the words and sentences describing
the event after a few seconds he felt a
headache and suffered from a slight nose
bleed after that the limp and pain from
the injury was gone and he could no
longer recall the event you see Dr
Wright that's the secret of SCP
401 Dr Henrik said with a mad gleam in
his eye this Library doesn't just let us
read the history of humanity it lets us
write it that's why you're here to test
the limit of this power and see what
this Library can do for the foundation
Dr Henrik soon provided Dr Wright with
footage of some of the many tests
conducted in the library and what Dr
Wright saw amazed him the books could
rewrite the laws of nature with alarming
speed as some unfortunate d-class
Personnel found out D
0546 was brought into a room with a full
head of hair the d-class Personnel was
instructed to scribble lost all hair
into his book and he soon started
scratching his head as he rapidly
started shedding hair after less than 2
minutes the the man was completely bald
d
0567 a young woman who had been brutally
injured when attacked by an escaping SCP
was bed written and would never walk
again according to all the foundation
doctors as the d-class Personnel used a
pen to scribble Over The Line in her
book describing her injury Dr W watches
she suffered a minor nose bleed and then
sat up getting out of bed as if she had
never been injured and no longer
remembered being attacked Dr CLA
Williams a foundation researcher sick
with cancer wrote Into the book about
curing her symptoms and then addressed
the camera explaining that this was her
third time altering her own book her
lymphoma symptoms had returned after
several months and 2 years respectively
but it seemed that as long as she
continued to make changes to her book
then she could keep the cancer at Bay
indefinitely but not all the tests ended
with positive results as drct right
moved on to another selection of tapes
labeled mortality tests a d-class person
who was given a fatal dose of drugs and
then had their death erased from their
book 45 minutes later miraculously
returned to life but showed significant
cognitive deficits after another d-class
an older woman killed in a Containment
Breach had her death erased from the
book but came back deeply Disturbed she
survived 15 days in containment
repeating send me back let me go over
and over again before committing suicide
a d-class Personnel killed 28 days prior
was brought back by writing return
turned back to life in their book but
died again just 13 minutes later from a
cerebral hemorrhage but it was the next
tape that was the most disturbing it
documented a new book that was written
by the foundation depicting the life of
a fictional man down to the slightest
detail it was carefully placed in the
correct position in the archives
resembling all the other books and Dr
Wright watched the tape in amazement as
the man resembling the fictional
character created for the books
spontaneously generated in SCP 401 one
almost immediately the man started
vomiting blood and died less than 2
minutes later the book carefully
described all the things he died from
and stated that this was exactly as it
was supposed to be the fake book then
disappeared into the archives never to
be seen again the archive knew when it
was being used to play with life and
death and it didn't want any part of it
the next tape wasn't a test at all it
was a video interview showing a Greek
speaking scientist speaking with an
ancient looking old man found living in
the archives slowly after its Discovery
by the foundation the man who described
himself as The Watcher of Alexandria
Eternal believed he was keeping the
archives safe from the Roman Empire and
the other Invaders He was unaware that
thousands of years had pass since his
watch began he had been using the books
to write himself another day of life and
to cure his ills ever since he began
guarding the library at the conclusion
of the interview he asked to leave and
this request was granted by the
foundation the ancient man died of old
age shortly after setting foot out of
the library while the library can't
technically cure death it does seem to
have nearly Limitless ability to prolong
life as long as someone is willing to
stay close by and never forgets to write
themselves another day where did this
incredible power come from an' 05
authorized investigation into the
origins of SCP 401 revealed that under
the archives carpet is a concrete floor
covered by a layer of Ash the ash was
carbon dated to between 70 and 880,000
years old in further analysis revealed
the ash is likely to be the remains of
burnt wood and paper despite there being
no known records within the archive
itself about a major fire having
occurred there Dr Wright didn't have
much time to dwell on the library's
great power of life because he was
suddenly shaken from his thoughts by the
sound of alarms was the library being
breached no it was Foundation officials
led by a man recognized as Dr Lincoln
Abrams the very man who assigned him to
this project and he did not look happy
he explained that he knew what Dr Wayan
Henri had been up to writing in books
changing the lives of subordinates in an
attempt to play God he knew about
everything of course because he had read
Dr henrik's own book he knew all of the
doctor's Secrets he knew everything no
I'm so close Dr Abrams I know I can
crack the archives rules there's a way
to conquer death here I can feel it Dr
rooms was done listening and with a wave
of his hand Foundation security took Dr
Henrik into custody for a debriefing and
likely demotion Dr Abrams then turned
his attention to the new Young
researcher Dr Wright eventful first day
I gather I'll appoint a new lead
scientist shortly but until then don't
disrupt anything remember the archive is
writing our stories as we speak it's not
very happy with Dr henrik's make sure
your story turns out better and with
that Dr Abrams and his security team
departed leaving Dr Herman Wright alone
with the endless archives of Alexandria
Eternal wondering what would be written
in his own tone as the sound of new
books popping into existence filled the
air with ominous rustling the fist
collides with Humphrey's face crumpling
him to the ground like a cheap greasy
Burger King rapper he feels the
lingering sting of the punch on his skin
and in the marrow of his cheekbone the
man who punched him a tall muscular
handsome man will refer to as Chad
stands above him with his fist still
clenched according to Chad Humphrey
Bingham the pale doughy 43-year-old
lying on the ground with a bruise
forming on his cheek had been
inappropriately hitting on his
girlfriend she told him to deal with the
situation and he had with one definitive
bark to leave his beloved alone Chad
turns and walks away leaving Humphrey on
the ground his face and pride equally
bruised a few hours later Humphrey is
sitting alone in a train car rattling
down the tracks in the direction of his
depressing bachelor's apartment he's
shaking with rage people they're
disgusting creatures really he thinks to
himself worthless animals that are
capable of nothing but cruelty and
exclusion they always let him down
always hurt him always made fun of him
every day getting up to face loneliness
and isol ation felt like being attacked
by a pack of wild dogs one thought Rings
loud and clear in his mind it'd be best
if someone had the guts to just wipe out
the human race no even more than that
annihilate all life in existence wipe
clean the slate and salt the Earth so
that somebody or something more worthy
could grow that was the Fate everyone
else deserve for making his 43 years on
this Earth so miserable but but beneath
all that there is another thought that's
making him smile he's got a plan a plan
that nobody else knows about a plan to
make everyone pay for every time they've
crossed Humphrey Bingham Humphrey you
see has an interesting job he works at
an infectious disease laboratory fans of
apocalyptic fiction are probably putting
together the picture already maybe he's
going to leak an infectious pathogen or
even worse combine and engineer multiple
pathogens together in order to make the
super virus capable of bringing Humanity
to its knees but that's where you would
be wrong Humphrey does have a vial in
his coat containing traces of the
Bubonic plague but his intentions with
it are actually far weirder soon enough
he arrives home and secretes himself
away in his Bleak little apartment it is
a drab and gray place except of course
for his weapons bizarre and impossible
blades iridescent like oil slicks and a
crazed rainbow of variety Blades of all
shapes and sizes from daggers to switch
blades to axes that technically weren't
legal to own you see Humphrey Bingham is
what we know as a m ninja a slang term
for someone who buys cheap and
impractical decorative weapons for
display around their home but the pride
of his collection has to be the
apocalyptic death metal sword as he's
dubbed it it sits on a stand in the
middle of all the others bright purple
and covered in so many sharp edges it's
almost impossible to hold he has been
refining and perfecting it for years in
some places the edges are a single atom
thin giving them inconceivable cutting
power and when we say that he has been
perfecting it we don't just mean
sharpening and polishing littered around
the room are different volumes on the
occult particularly those concerned with
enchanting objects he's been conducting
spells and rituals grinding up desert
locust shells and illegally purchased
human bones and saying incantations he's
drawn all the proper pentagrams and
tonight he's obtained the decisive
ingredient he needs to make his plans a
reality the Bubonic plague sample saying
the complex incomprehensible words of a
spell he' memorized Humphrey Bingham
produces the vial and carefully pours it
across the apocalyptic death metal sword
it glows and tingles radiating with pure
power and Humphrey finds himself
giggling with uncontrollable Glee he
imagines scenes from The Book of
Revelation his favorite part of the New
Testament where Satan Rises and the war
between him and God destroys and later
remakes the Earth he imagines his mighty
sword as an agent of almost Heavenly
power dealing brutal judgment on the
evil and the weak back in reality
Humphrey's insane dream might just be
coming true but in in an even grander
manner than he'd imagined the
apocalyptic death metal sword floats off
of its stand but it isn't alone three
other smaller swords from his collection
also rise up the weapons that had been
practiced for all of his experiments it
seems they'd been a success a terrible
rousing success but Umphrey's dreams
quickly turn into a nightmare as the
enchanted swords begin to fight each
other but it isn't some free-for-all
Battle Royale all the smaller swords are
teaming up against the apocalyptic death
metal sword and the smaller swords are
losing as the wildly flailing death
sword slashes them into tiny fragments
of metal it is an act of rampant stide
and Humphrey can only stare on in horror
though the Rampage is nowhere near over
when the lesser of the swords are no
more the apocalyptic death metal sword
flails insanely as though battling
invisible monsters already it's far
beyond Humphrey bingham's control but
there is a method to this madness a
method that Humphrey himself is
literally unable to see the apocalyptic
death metal sword is so dedicated to the
Grand Mission of destroying life that
even bacteria cannot Escape its
stainless steel wrath on a microscopic
level every swing cleanly Cuts one of
the microscopic life forms in half this
terrifying weapon truly does not plan on
letting any of its potential victims
Escape up to and including the
unfortunate Humphrey Bingham himself
before he's even had time to scream and
run the sword turns on him it flies in
his Direction at Mock four speed and
unleashes an impossible flurry of
slashes by the time it's done there's
literally nothing left not even blood
just an empty room full of broken swords
where the creator of this apocalyptic
weapon has been cleaved into Oblivion on
the atomic level but the sword is not
done it slashes through the door and
heads out into the wider World ready to
pursue its Deadly Mission it isn't long
until researchers at a local Foundation
containment site catch wind of something
strange going on in the city they
intercept some frantic police chatter
about officers fighting off a sword no
not a person holding a sword just a
sword rather than just assume it's some
kind of strange police incident like the
time those two on duty cops avoided
investigating a robbery to get a Snorlax
on Pokémon go the site director quickly
dispatches a heavily armed mobile task
force on the scene it is a complete
bloodbath officers and civilians lay
dead in the streets as the sword
continues to fly around at impossible
speed what had initially been several
squad cars worth of responding officers
had been reduced to a mere handful of
scared stragglers what they've seen
today would completely rewrite their
understanding of reality even if it
wasn't actively murdering their
co-workers and trying to murder them too
in the brief periods where the
apocalyptic death metal sword isn't
cutting down cops and civilians it is
continuing to flail madly through the
air slicing more insects and microscopic
beings seemingly nothing can stop its
Rampage and that's when the mobile task
force helicopter arrives along with two
ground units in armored tactical
vehicles for support it's the kind of
precautions you can expect when the SCP
Foundation isn't entirely sure what
they're up against and little do they
know they're going to need all of them
if they want any hope of surviving and
defeating the apocalyptic death metal
sword but they're going to lose a lot of
good men before then MTF Troopers start
repelling down from the helicopter
wielding Advanced tactical assault
rifles they're able to lock on to the
Diabolical malul Ninja Blade and open
fire hitting it with a hail of
armor-piercing bullets but those bullets
resoundingly fail to pierce whatever
anomalous armor maintains the
apocalyptic death metal sword's
structural Integrity the bullets
ricochet off making sounds like popcorn
kernels rattling around in a tin can the
blades counteroffensive would be a lot
more effective it locks on to the most
dangerous Target first perhaps out of
pure bad luck on the part of the MTF
squads the helicopter pilot the sword
flies for him faster than he could
possibly move his vehicle out of its
path it skewers the cockpit traveling
straight through his chest and out the
other side of the helicopter the vehicle
consequently spins out and explodes Lo s
torpedoing its burning carcass down onto
the street below things are starting to
get interesting as the other operatives
pile out of the ground vehicles and
start firing on the flash of deadly
purple steel the massacre continues the
sword fing through Foundation tactical
armor like Playdoh their bullets can't
harm the device or even really slow it
down a frightening thought passes
through the minds of one of the
operatives if this thing is left
unchecked for long enough it could
blossom into an XK Class end of the
world scenario there is no follow-up
thought though because the sword passed
through his mind moments afterwards
leaving him cold and dead on the ground
as the battle rages on Victory clearly
on the side of the apocalyptic death
metal sword the egg heads back at the
nearest Foundation containment site are
screaming to think up of a contingency
plan an entity wielding a weapon is
easily enough to kill or at least
disable but a weapon without an entity
that still keeps on attacking feels
almost impossible they're desperately
trying to collect information about the
anomalous item from the field but
anytime one of the operatives is able to
radio back they're killed by the sword
before they can impart any useful
information all that's left to try is
the nuclear option thankfully not
literally when conventional teams fail
they have certain experimental mobile
task forces namely mobile task force
Omega 7 Pandora's Box and one particular
member of that team who has expertise in
that area SCP
076-2
AEL The Immortal Warrior years before
the incident of mass killing that would
cause the team to be disbanded while the
apocalyptic death metal sword did its
thing the rest of the team was being
dispatched to fetch Abel out of Cold
Storage the second that this terrifying
tattooed Warrior is told that he'll be
up against another blade he's chomping
at the bit he's dragged into a
high-speed helicopter and taken to the
the scene as quickly as possible fitted
with an earpiece so he can tell exactly
what he learns about the apocalyptic
death metal sword over to Mission
command Abel agreed on the condition
that he could go all out on his enemy
for once his handlers didn't mind
granting him that permission after all
nobody was even really sure if it was
possible to hurt an enemy like this
about an hour into the Rampage Abel
arrives touching down on the concrete so
hard that it buckles beneath his feet he
sees the sword floating there hideous
and garish even by his standards is his
opponent invisible it doesn't matter
he'll slay them all the same he produces
two of his obsidian swords and charges
in as the sword seems to notice his
presence and flies towards him at
incredible speeds it takes his truly
superlative reflexes along with his
considerable strength to Parry the
weapon at the decisive minute before it
can pierce his wretched heart it's so
much faster than he expected he's almost
impressed the blade does not wait it
circles and Strikes him again as he
deflects and Strikes at it with his own
swords and then something impossible
happens his swords break this hideous
purple blade has slice clean through
them causing them to fall onto the floor
in multiple black pieces this is
impossible how could this blade have
bested his own over his earpiece his
handlers ask him for information on the
blade anything they can use AEL says
that the weapon doesn't make sense it
has the quality of mere steel but it was
somehow unbreakable that is all the
handlers need to hear they begin
immediately putting their contingency
measures into place they just need able
to buy them a little more time will he
be able to give the apocalyptic death
metal sword a good enough fight the
battle is strangely one of the toughest
he's ever faced his opponent feels no
pain no fear it's doesn't even think or
feel it attacks and kills on pure
Instinct every time he pulls out a new
weapon an axe a sword a Warhammer a
chainsaw it's already upon Him slashing
away with unimaginable speed and
ferocity it matches his own as every
Parry is met with a perfect counter
Parry he's now getting to grips with the
fact that his opponent isn't holding a
weapon his opponent is a weapon but he
still refus uses to let this be an easy
fight he summons a huge obsidian
broadsword from the space between spaces
and lunges in clashing blades with the
edges of the apocalyptic death metal
sword he feels its strength and its
speed its desire to deal death to
everything it was pure it was glorious
when the foundation reinforcements
arrive Abel is dead don't worry he'll
get better with the apocalyptic death
metal sword sticking out of his chest
after finding out that the sword is made
of steel the foundation operatives were
able to devise a powerful electromagnet
one capable of getting this unruly
weapon of mass destruction under some
semblance of control with the sword
enables body retrieved this supernatural
weapon now labeled s SCP
3749 is placed inside a vacuum chamber
completely sterilized in that scenario
the weapon simply shook around on the
floor a shadow of its terrifying former
self without even bacteria to destroy it
can only turn on itself and lay there in
the dark another dangerous anomaly
secured contained and soon to be
protected a textbook case for the
foundation's central Mission these days
SCP 3749 sits inside a fitted
hermetically sealed chamber full of
kinetic gel designed to suppress its
constant urge to slash and stab any and
all life if ever that seal is broken we
just hope you're nearby or in the very
brief period you'll still be alive you
may learn firsthand what it feels like
to be sushi in that regard the miserable
Legacy of Humphrey Bingham is unlike the
man himself alive and well burning
neighborhoods strings of horrific ax
murders a burger joint selling human
flesh and only one question you mad bro
fans of internet memes from the mid
2000s might remember one inescapable
image commonly known as as Trollface
Trollface and his trademark grin
symbolized mischief and troublemaking
and generally making the world a more
chaotic place over time as is often the
case on the internet new variations on
the image began to spring up as users
created their own spin on Trollface at
first it was all relatively harmless but
then again this is the internet nothing
online stays harmless forever over time
more Sinister variations on on Trollface
began to surface memes consisting of
joke instructions that took a dark
destructive turn this new spin on the
Trollface quickly became known as trolia
and often featured disturbing content
presented in a joking prankster format
still not something to be too concerned
about just standard edgy posting trying
to get a reaction by shocking people
right not exactly on December 24th 2020
in Melbourne Australia a college student
named Lee Miller received an early
Christmas present from her classmate and
ex-boyfriend Peter witkins the two had
parted on relatively good terms and she
was glad to receive a gift from him when
she opened it she was delighted to see
that he had purchased her a jar of
expensive French facial moisturizer one
she had been interested in trying back
when they were together as she prepared
to do her skincare routine that night
she thought about how thoughtful the
gift was and how sweet Peter was maybe
she' made a mistake breaking things off
maybe after the holidays she could reach
out and see if they could give things
another shot as she unscrewed the jar of
moisturizer she didn't notice that its
color and smell seemed just a bit off
she just dipped her fingers inside and
began to apply the cream to her face all
of a sudden she realized what a horrible
mistake that was her face began to burn
her skin screaming out in a pain like
none she'd ever felt before she screamed
clawing at her face desperate for a way
to make it stop neighbors heard the
screams and called Emergency Services
when paramedics arrived on the scene her
condition had gotten even worse they
restrained her sedated her and took her
to the hospital for treatment the face
cream was brought in for testing and was
found to have been tampered with it had
been spiked with gimpy gimpy one of the
world's most excruciatingly painful
plants Peter was promptly brought in for
questioning but refused to explain why
he had done it he was charged with
assault and officers inspected his home
for anything that might suggest a motive
on his computer they found the most
recent post he had read before
presumably committing the crime it was a
Trolla meme formatted as a comic and it
read want to get back at your girlfriend
step one find out her favorite facial
cream step two procure the facial cream
step three obtain urien plant use gloves
step four blend the leaves with the
cream then repack it step five give
girlfriend the gift the meme contained a
six step but it was redacted in all
official records for reasons that will
soon become clear this incident caught
the attention of the SCP Foundation who
swiftly looked into the meme as a
potential anomaly as they were
conducting their investigation it
happened again another troia meme
another horrible crime with an
inexplicable motive on December 28th
2020 in bond AKA Indonesia 15 terminally
ill patients were found dead in their
hospital beds that wouldn't necessarily
be caused for alarm given the nature of
their conditions except for the cause of
death the patients did not pass away due
to their illnesses instead each and
every one of them was killed by carbon
monoxide poisoning at first the case was
a mystery until security footage
revealed that one of the hospital's
orderlies Aziz hiat replaced the
patient's oxygen tanks with tanks of
carbon monoxide he was promptly arrested
and brought in for question questioning
during the interrogation he repeated
again and again that he was not trying
to harm the patients but he was
delivering them the police officers
asked who he was trying to deliver them
to but he refused to answer a search
through his computer browser history
uncovered another troll meme this one
read want to help people step one get a
job at a hospital step two make friends
with the patients step three enter
oxygen tank room step four replace tanks
with carbon monoxide step five release
them from their defective vessels the
SCP Foundation had been in the process
of formulating a hypothesis but now it
was confirmed these variations on the
troll sh meme contained a Cognito
hazardous switch that would cause a
reader to carry out the acts described
in the comic the switch appeared to
specifically be contained in the
conclusive line hence its removal from
all official records of any identified
anomalous memes an estimated 25% of
those exposed to an anomalous meme would
be affected by this Cognito Hazard the
phenomenon was given the designation as
CP
6661 and the memes themselves SCP 6661
D1 these first two incidents were
nicknamed the pretty girl incident and
the sleepy time incident respectively
several other notable incidents occurred
following the discovery of SCP 6661 on
January 20th 2021 the Harvester Valley
incident occurred Oliver dardin of
Alberta Canada packed his bags full of
camping supplies fresh drinking water a
flashlight and an axe he kissed his wife
and children goodbye and he drove out to
the local tourist Campground after
Darkness fell he left his tent Axe in
Hand and walked from Camp to Camp
slaughtering anyone he came across he
managed to kill 10 people and injure 14
before he was killed by the authorities
everyone who knew Oliver was shocked
saying he had no history of violent
Behavior he wouldn't even kill a spider
when he found one inside his wife gave
the authorities permission to examine
his internet activity and sure enough
they found a trolia meme left open want
to have a good holiday step one pack
necessary equipment and items step two
say goodbye to family step three drive
to the valley campgrounds step four find
local Shepherd and his flock step five
steal a little lamb step six relish upon
its flesh for it will be your dying meal
step seven d
expunged after reading the meme the
foundation determined that a nearby
farmer was indeed missing one of his
sheep the bones of the missing sheep
were later discovered near the
campground where the attack took place
this new finding suggested that the
Cognito hazardous effects tended to
result in a largely literal
interpretation of the given memes text
Oliver himself could not be questioned
about his actions due to his death on
the scene so there were no more answers
to be uncovered in his case on February
16 16 2021 in Bratislava Slovakia a man
named Joseph prasa began displaying
unusual behavior at around 0200 hours he
drove through his neighborhood in his
water truck and began using it to spray
kerosene upon nearby buildings
throughout the area the sound and the
smell woke several neighbors who
attempted to reason with Joseph and make
him stop what he was doing he ignored
them as if in a trance and carried on
with his task frightened for their
safety as well as that of their clearly
unwell neighbor they called emergency
services to the scene Emergency Services
arrived to find Joseph standing in front
of the active nozzle kerosene blasting
directly onto him he didn't even seem to
notice as the authorities approached him
calling out to him asking him to come
with them he acknowledged their presence
he smiled broadly and pulled something
from his pocket all too late they
realized what it was a road flare he
ignited it and the area was swiftly
engulfed in flames 26 people were killed
in the blast and hundreds of thousands
in property damage occurred as a result
that was shocking enough but additional
emergency responders who arrived at the
scene saw something even more bizarre it
began to rain putting out some of the
Flames as the water touched the kerosene
soaked bodies and Landscape paramedics
were completely taken aback as they saw
corpses and bits of rubble begin to
float up into the air up into the sky
one man later described what he had seen
to the police saying it was as if they
were floating on the water that was
falling from the sky the authorities
dismissed this account but the SCP
Foundation knew better this had to be
another troia incident indeed it was and
on Joseph's computer they found the
guilty meme oil is lighter than water
step one cover yourself in oil step two
feels good step three cover others in
oil step four data expunged somehow this
particular instance of SCP 6661 had
managed to alter the laws of physics to
bend them to its will it was a troubling
development and not something they cared
to see repeated containment procedures
were swiftly put into place webcrawlers
monitored the internet for any
appearances of troia particularly those
that seem to have Cognito hazardous
properties if they could track these
instances and delete them from
circulation perhaps they could prevent
any more needless destruction during the
monitoring process some of the web
crawlers detected an instance of SCP
66611 with a heavily distorted
concluding step before expunging the
step Junior researcher Mikel Ramirez
edited out the Distortion and scanned
the image through a spectrogram
generator this was it should be noted
without prior authorization the
spectrogram generated audio three
recognizable
words Junior researcher Ramirez was
reprimanded for breaching protocol call
but his work proved to be valuable
enough to Warrant additional research
with the sign off of the 05 Council a
spectrogram was constructed with a reply
to this question and spread through the
internet the foundation's response was
yes we see you who are you and why are
you doing this within 24 hours of the
foundation's response another SCP 66611
instance with a similar Distortion was
found the Distortion was isolated and
scanned through a spectrogram generator
once more
[Music]
stated people forget you m i Am m i be
weaker people now like darkness and
expion embrace Shadow chaos f
I exist people see me I
life this Revelation gave the foundation
a new theory on the nature of SCP 6661
the initial Trollface meme was so
popular so widespread and beloved that
the collective energy directed towards
it created a thought form able to
manifest via the meme when Trollface
declined in popularity over the years
the thought form became desperate to
achieve the same relevance again it
gravitated towards darker subject matter
toward the shocking and disturbing in
order to get attention this resulted in
the creation of SCP
66611 an opportunity for the thought
form to feel seen again when it does not
feel seen when it is not fed energy and
attention the thought form becomes weak
and desperate the Cognito hazardous
effects may not be deliberate at all but
rather an unfortunate side effect of
this particular manifestation an
additional theory was proposed the way
to limit the effects of SCP
66611 to perhaps even eradicate it is to
make the original troll face popular
again the troll must be fed at first the
foundation was reluctant to put this
Theory into practice it seemed patent
absurd to many of the higher-ups but the
percentage of susceptible individuals
began to increase and more and more
incidents occurred in July of 2021
residents of of a small Virginia Town
began to go missing one by one until
over a dozen people had mysteriously
disappeared there appeared to be no
common link between the missing persons
until one unlikely thread surfaced tying
them all together shortly before their
disappearance each person had eaten a
meal at Billy's Burgers the local burger
joint police interrogated all employees
but no new information turned up they
checked security camera footage but only
one of the cameras at the small local
business was operational and it only
captured the restaurant's main entrance
it was beginning to look like one more
Dead lead that is until one of the
investigating officers heard his stomach
Rumble and decided to grab a burger and
fries for the road back at the police
station the officer sat down to enjoy
his lunch taking a big juicy bite out of
his Burger suddenly he felt something
hard crack against his tooth he reached
into his mouth and fished it out at
first he didn't believe his eyes but
sure enough there was a human finger
bone he hopped back in his police car
drove back to Billy's burgers and
demanded to investigate the kitchen
there wasn't anything out of the
ordinary right away but he trusted his
gut and the bite of the burger that he
had almost put it in he confiscated the
freshly ground meat and had it analyzed
the results came back and his stomach
dropped it was human once more the
police officer drove back to the Burger
Joint this time his lights were flashing
his siren was blaring and he was ready
to make an arrest when he arrived arriv
the place was eerily quiet all the
lights were off he drew his weapon and
crept toward the back where he found the
fry cook Jeffrey TBS operating the meat
grinder next to the machine he could
make out bloody scraps of employee
uniforms and suddenly realized why the
place was so quiet Jeffrey was making
his co-workers into Burgers he arrested
Jeffrey and brought the young man into
custody all he would say over and over
again was I'm I made them better the SCP
Foundation caught wind of this hor Ying
case and arrived to conduct their own
investigation they found another Cognito
hazardous meme this one read everyone
loves Burgers step one get job at a
burger place step two improve on the
recipe step three Source your own meat
step four profit step five expunged the
foundation attempted to interrogate
Jeffrey as well but he was still not
forthcoming he did say one thing however
he requested that for his dying meal in
prison he be given a burger after after
this incident the order was given the
Trollface experiment would be carried
out a team of researchers sociologists
and statisticians was assembled and
asked to design images and media
involving Trollface now designated as CP
66612 the images were then disseminated
across the foundation internet
attempting to saturate the media with
this mimic agent until it achieved a
status colloquially known as dank this
team was designated task force hexan 9
meme machine machine the initial
experiment was a success and the
incidence began to slightly reduce the
all clear was given and SCP 661 D2 was
disseminated across the internet again
incident numbers decreased this allowed
for standard containment procedures to
be put in place procedures still in use
today the foundation has established a
think tank to observe the trends and
popularity of SCP 6661 D2 if its
popularity declines the think tank will
evaluate the best course of action to
take s CP 6612 based mimic agents are to
be spread across various social media
sites and the internet at large as well
as the foundation internet Foundation
webcrawlers must consistently scan the
internet at large for instances of SCP
66611 and look for active SCP 66611
events if any instances are found the
concluding instructions must be redacted
whenever possible any Personnel that is
going to deal directly with SCP 66611
must be mimetically in calculated before
being assigned to the anomaly oh wait it
seems as though there's one more
mimetically infected comic let's see
here want to see the best videos on
YouTube step one log on step two find
SCP explained step three subscribe step
four ring the bell step five redacted
the SCP Foundation does their best to
live up to their famous namesake they
secure and contain anomalies and
monsters from all around the world or
sometimes even offworld and protect the
public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose however
despite their efforts to maintain
security and keep their subjects under
lock and key there are sometimes
creatures so clever so devious and so
determined to escape their captivity and
wreck havoc on the world that even the
SCP Foundation struggles to keep them
from getting free one example is SCP
035 or the possessive mask SCP 035 is
one of the most dangerous test subjects
in SCP Foundation custody and its mere
Presence at the foundation has resulted
in Untold damage death and destruction
it seems innocent enough to the
untrained eye The Mask which resembles a
classic white porcelain comedy mask
though it occasionally changes its
expression to tragedy has been in
existence since at least the
1800s in the late 19th century the
foundation discovered the mask in a
sealed Crypt beneath an abandoned home
in Venice it is unknown how it got there
or how the foundation knew to look for
it if there was ever an explanation for
its Discovery it has long since been
removed or redacted from the
foundation's archives you're probably
wondering how can a simple mask leave
multiple season Foundation employees
dead well like everything at the SCP
Foundation this mask Is Not What It
Seems there is a reason its
classification is ker a designation that
refers to an entity that's excessively
difficult to contain and it couples this
difficulty with a pronounced hostility
towards human life and the ability to
cause widespread destruction in the
event of a Containment Breach these are
the qualities that the Poor Unfortunate
Souls assigned to guard SCP 035 would
come to understand all too well the
possessive mask is a parasitic entity
constantly seeking out a host willing to
put it on any human being in the mask's
proximity experiences a sudden
unexplainable urge to put it on and once
they do There's No Going Back SCP
Foundation research has determined that
once a host has put on the mask their
brain waves are replaced with an
alternative pattern this one coming from
the mask rendering the host effectively
brain dead once the host brain function
has been eliminated the mask takes over
piloting their body and even speaking
through them however the mask can only
occupy a host for a small amount of time
before the body begins to Decay and
decompose eventually rotting away
completely leaving nothing but
desiccated Flesh and Bones where there
once was a person SCP 035 is capable of
possessing any humanoid being whether
that's an actual human being or a
lifeless humanoid shape despite all
their research the SCP Foundation
unknowingly gave the mask all the tools
and resources it needed to break
containment and leave a trail of bodies
in its wake for a Time the mask was
given host privileges meaning that it
was purposely allowed to occupy a host
in order to speak with the scientist
studying it in order to avoid murky
ethical issues the host was usually
something inanimate like a mannequin or
a statue these conditions however
unsettling allowed the researchers to
carry out interviews with the
Consciousness housed inside the mask in
the hope of beginning to understand it
and its motivations however SCP 035 lost
all access to its host privileges after
it almost pulled off an unprecedented
shocking and nearly catastrophic escape
attempt in its early days of the
facility when it was still allowed host
privileges it was contained in a tripl
locked room and monitored by several
research Personnel these were
experienced researchers who had been
with the foundation for a minimum of 5
years each an unusually long tenure in
such a dangerous and mentally corrosive
line of work these research staff
members were thought to be the most
capable of handling interactions with
the mask and be able to resist its
attempts at manipulation unfortunately
these assumptions were naive and
seriously underestimated the mask's
power research on the mask indicates
that the mask is incredibly intelligent
and a skilled manipulator it has a
photographic memory intelligence that
would rank it in the 99th percentile of
humans and the ability to incite
dramatic changes in the behavior and
people that it talks to one particularly
in famous interview between the entity
and an unnamed doctor at the foundation
suggested that the mask may even possess
telepathic abilities the mask was able
to give details about the doctor's life
that no one else was privy to including
knowledge of an affair that his wife was
having following the interview the
doctor suffered a psychotic break and
committed suicide just 24 hours later
the mask is able to use its Superior
intelligence charismatic personality and
mind reading abilities to get inside the
heads of those it speaks with it will
pull out any and all psychological stops
to get What It Wants leaving Broken
minds and Spirits in its wake it was
really only a matter of time before it
used this skill set to its advantage and
attempted to escape its confinement the
day of the escape attempt was like any
other the research staff a team of three
intelligent experienced men checked into
the facility measured the conditions of
the Mask containment unit and began the
process of interviewing The Mask like
normal its motions were slow and looked
to require great effort as its current
host was beginning to degrade Beyond use
the mask was attached to the blank face
of a mannequin and corrosive black
liquid could be seen oozing from its eye
and mouth holes this liquid is excreted
by the mask at a near constant rate and
it's thought to be at at least partially
responsible for the accelerated decay of
the host bodies in spite of the entity's
unsettling nightmarish appearance it was
just another day's work for the men
assigned to monitor SCP
035 and so they carried on with their
daily routine everything was going
according to plan until one of the men
Dr Jones began to behave erratically he
demanded that his fellow scientists
leave him alone with the mask for a
while and allow him to engage in a
private conversation with it it is
unknown what exactly the two spoke about
while the other two scientists were
absent as the security footage captured
had no sound however several minutes
into the conversation in the footage Dr
Jones can be seen dissolving into a fit
of Tears laying on the ground and
shaking with sobs as the mask
dispassionately watches he then climbs
onto his knees begging the mask for
something before he Embraces it he holds
the mannequin in his arms for five
straight minutes weeping again before
they separate after this disturbing
emotional display
Dr Jones brought the other scientists
back into the room with him what
happened next is still uncertain but
there are a few things that we know for
sure the other scientists began to speak
with the mask in later interviews the
other scientists were bordering on
incoherent babbling about various
traumas from their lives one repeatedly
referred to a drunk driving accident
where a dear friend was killed and he
was at fault another simply cried out
for his mother again and again whatever
the masks said to them it was enough to
completely destroy their m mental health
after The two scientists had been
emotionally devastated by The Mask Dr
Jones escalated the situation further Dr
Jones removed the mask from the decaying
mannequin body and shocking everyone who
had later reviewed the security footage
placed it onto his own face once the
mask was in place the security footage
ends at the command of the Mask which
was now speaking through Dr Jones the
other two men switched off all security
camera monitoring SCP 035 containment
facility
The Mask piloting the body of Dr Jones
like a horrible fleshy puppet made its
way through the facility avoiding
detection until it reached the exit
doors where it was finally stopped by a
team of over a dozen security guards
knowing the dangers of touching the mask
all Foundation employees involved in the
recontainment of SCP 035 refused to
remove it from Dr Jones's face instead
he was placed in the lock room with the
mask still on left alone to be observed
over the security cameras until his body
had decomposed opposed Beyond use his
body paced back and forth in the cell
for days flesh rotting and dropping away
only until senu and Bone remained only
when the bones began to turn black and
brittle crumbling apart into dust did
the body finally stop moving his family
was notified the mask was carefully
removed from what was left of his body
and his remains were destroyed the other
two scientists involved in the SCP 035
escape attempt were terminated and their
files destroyed after this incident a
few more failed Escape attempts and the
acknowledgement of the devastation that
could have been caused if the mask had
made its way out into the general
population SCP 035 lost its host
privileges altogether several research
staff protested this decision insisting
that there was more to be learned from
speaking with the entity and citing
valuable information that it had given
about other scps however the risk was
determined to considerably outweigh the
potential reward and the request to
reinstate 0 35's host privileges were
denied several staff members went so far
as to erupt into violent outbursts on 0
35's behalf attacking their supervisors
who refused to provide the mask with a
new host clawing at them with
animalistic rage any staff members that
submitted a request to reinstate said
privileges were considered a security
threat and reassigned to a different SCP
or in some cases terminated any staff
member who had Direct contact with SCP
035 was also terminated in order to
avoid the risk of any more staff aided
Escape attempts the mask is now kept in
a hermetically sealed glass case and
there is a psychologist on call to
provide assistance to anyone guarding it
in case of adverse effects on their
mental health from the mask's presence
Personnel that work around the mask even
in its current dormant State experience
frequent violent outbursts and a higher
rate of suicide even without a host the
mask corrosive effects have spread
across its containment facility the
walls of the room have begun to secrete
the same black liquid that emanates from
the m mask which tests have revealed to
be highly contaminated human blood that
damages the structural Integrity of the
walls following prolonged contact this
blood has begun to form patterns on the
walls spelling out words and phrases in
Italian Latin Greek and Sanskrit as well
as depicting drawings of ritual
sacrifice and mutilation staff members
also report hearing unintelligible
whispering and horrifying high-pitch
laughter when in proximity to the mask
further exposure to the mask results in
migraines hemorrhages around the eyes
mouth and nose and an eventual psychotic
brain between the corrosive substance
appearing on the walls and the physical
and psychological damage to employees
SCP 035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are
debates among staff as to whether the
entity can in fact be contained at all
as soon as possible SCP 035 will be
moved into a new containment facility
and its previous cell will be isolated
from the rest of the foundation's
property and destroyed for the safety of
all involved we can only hope that the
new containment procedures are more
effective than the last ones and that
this mask never makes its way into the
world again if it does who knows how
many lives it will claim in the meantime
if you ever come across a strange maskk
and feel a nearly uncontrollable urge to
put it on ignore the whispered please to
just try it ignore the echoing laughter
and The Sensation of something older and
more powerful than you can imagine
rumaging through your deepest dark
secret thoughts turn around and run as
fast as you can in the other direction
you'll be glad that you did nothing in
life can prepare you for the raw heat of
a house on fire throwing an arm up in
front of his eyes and clasping a
handkerchief to his mouth Robert
chatford hacked up half of the contents
of his lungs glancing at the material he
saw that his Flem was black poisoned by
the smoke a beam collapsed in front of
him sending a fresh wave of burning air
into into his face so hot that it felt
like it was going to Scorch his ears off
he had to run he had to get out of the
house but he knew he couldn't his mother
was upstairs Robert barreled his way
through the Flames shouldering open
doors and stumbling along hallways the
air was so thick with smoke that he
could barely breathe so he collapsed to
the floor and started to crawl on his
stomach he reached the first step of the
grand staircase and started to heave
himself up one at a time feel feeling
the heat of the house threatening to
engulf him more with every inch he
climbed but he hadn't made it more than
five steps before there was an enormous
creaking sound and the whole staircase
collapsed beneath him Sparks rushed up
into the air and swirled around the room
Flames licked at the walls all around
him as Robert looked around at the
collapsed staircase he knew that it was
hopeless with tears streaming down his
cheeks he pushed himself forward and ran
out of the house the firemen swarmed
past him filling the building and
shouting to one another but Robert just
stood there staring up at the top floor
window on the other side of the glass
surrounded by billowing smoke he looked
up at his mother sitting as she always
did on her rocking chair utterly
motionless as the house burned around
her in an undisclosed facility in the
United States of America you will find
what may well be the lowest security
containment cell in the entire SCP
Foundation there was no heavily armored
door no bulletproof glass no machine
guns about to drop down from the ceiling
at any point in fact there's very little
in the way of containment at all they
often leave the door to the cell wide
open there is a window but on the other
side of it isn't a crowd of researchers
security guards and agents ready to
spring into action at a moment's notice
it's just a normal double glazed window
that looks out across a Vista of fields
trees and a couple of power lines facing
the window is an old armchair in which
the concrete man sits SCP
014 he spends all of his day every day
staring out of the window this view
specifically was chosen because very
little changes in it night turns to day
the trees change with the seasons and it
rains occasionally but there are no
roads no new buildings springing up
nothing to distinguish it from how it
looked in 193 7 beside him is a small
table home to a record player in the
corner of the room there's an antique
set of shelves that house three dozen
old records all dated from the 1930s or
earlier all day every day the music
plays out of the old speaker every so
often as researchers walk up and down
the corridor if they hear that there
isn't any music playing they'll come
into the room and change the record over
for a new one the newest researchers
check in with SCP 014 to see if if he's
okay he rarely responds and so before
long they stop asking you would think
therefore that the concrete man is
elderly approaching the Twilight years
of his life but the man who sits there
in his chair staring out of the window
and listening to music from almost 100
years ago appears to be just 30 years
old friends of Robert Chadford reported
a noticeable change in his demeanor
following the fire and death of his
mother he had lost his father not long
before to a workplace accident William
chatford had been a construction worker
climbing up the girders of New York's
emerging Skyline pouring concrete and
piling bricks he had been working on a
new building one that was said to be the
tallest in the world called the Empire
State Building day after day he would
climb the cranes Teeter precariously
over the dizzying drops any slight
mistake and he would plummet hundreds of
feet often to the busy streets below
sure enough one day day William chatford
worst fears came to life he was walking
on a gang plank that wobbled and bent
with every step he took on his shoulders
was a metal bar with a bucket of
concrete dangled precariously from each
tip he walked this route every day but
clearly that day proved too much for the
wood to take the board splintered and
split beneath him plunging him down and
down through the scaffolding William
desperately reached out an arm and
managed to grasp the edge of a girder he
hung there helplessly staring up at his
colleagues high above him he cried out
for help and upon seeing him they began
to scramble down level by level to try
and rescue him he just needed to hang on
for a moment longer and they would
rescue him but one of them knocked over
a bucket of concrete William Chadford
could do nothing but watch as the heavy
sludge slowly tumbled towards his face
he tried to dodge it but it was no use
the company told Mrs chatford that this
had been William's Saving Grace that he
had been unconscious for the long fall
down to the streets below his fellow
workers knew that this wasn't the case
they heard his screams all the way down
Mrs chatford didn't believe any of it
they were lying all of them the company
his co-workers everybody she knew what
had really killed him it was the same
thing that was killing her slowly the
same thing that had been passed on to
their son concrete poisoning she'd
approached the Wall Street Journal New
York Times and any Outlet she could but
none of them were remotely in interested
in the story there were chemicals in the
concrete it wasn't safe to use it never
had been she'd been working in nursing
homes and seen the effects of concrete
on construction workers they'd become
paralyzed unable to move spending so
many years breathing concrete air
letting it absorb into their skin their
bodies had slowly started to turn into
it she knew it she started to go crazy
pinning up news clippings medical
journals photographs Maps anything she
could find all over her walls her entire
bedroom she had red string hanging from
the walls and ceiling connecting to
every surface Robert watched helplessly
from the doorway unable to do anything
as he saw his mother steadily entering
into psychosis but the further her
paranoia went the less energy she seemed
to have for it weeks went by and her
manic fervor was replaced with lethargy
she got slower and slower in her
movements talked less and less at meal
times and began to sit down for extended
chunks of the day Robert assuming that
she was tired from grief did what he
could to help he carried an armchair up
to her room and placed it in the corner
by the window so that she could look out
over the world around her he thought she
was resting but it soon became apparent
that she wasn't really resting she was
withdrawing almost freezing over
desperate to try and get his mother to
re-engage with the world Robert sat down
with her to try and understand all of
her conspiracy theories around his
father's death she explained slowly and
calmly that the concrete being used in
New York was poisoned cursed she didn't
know where it had been dug up from how
it had been mixed or who was behind it
but she was getting close maybe it was
the US government maybe it was the same
witches maybe it was God himself but she
knew her husband and she knew he
wouldn't have fallen that day it walked
across that plank thousands of times
without incident there was no way he
would have made that mistake Robert
tried to connect the dots of what she
was saying did she really think that it
was the concrete that had killed his
father she said that it was and that the
same concrete is now killing her she
showed him her hands turned them over
front and back under the light for him
to inspect they looked just like normal
hands elderly wrinkled with deep veins
popping out but normal she scratched at
them and tried to faint pain for the
effects of her fingers look she said you
see that powder coming off them that's
concrete powder but Robert didn't see
any of it the concrete man came to the
foundation's attention a couple decades
ago construction workers in New York in
the late 1990s were hard at work
clearing out the foundations for a new
skyscraper the site was built on top of
what used to be a residential block the
one Intrepid Builder soon discovered
Something That Shook him to his core
there was an old Cellar beneath where
the building used to be the lock on it
was Heavy thick with rust and had been
open for close to 70 years he and his
team managed to pry it open put on their
flashlights and went inside what they
found was a basement apartment still
sitting there beneath the rubble it was
a relic of its time thick dust covered
every surface ugly wallpaper surrounded
them and ancient appliances covered with
rust sat in the kitchen it was almost
like walking through a haunted house the
builders joked about ghosts stalking
these corridors as they made their way
through until they reached the bedroom
sliding the door open they faced a man
sitting there staring at them from an
old armchair the four Burly Builders
screamed like little girls for a split
second then burst out laughing when they
realized that the man wasn't real he
must have been a wax work or something
he was sitting so perfectly still and
hadn't reacted at all to their presence
they went over to inspect what he was
made out of they tapped on his forehead
lifted his arms and dropped them and
were surprised at how convincing the
fake man was that was of course until he
politely asked them not to touch him
this time they really did scream like
girls running straight out of the
basement into a local police station
this basement apartment was where Robert
Chadford moved following the fire in his
parents' home and the death of his
paralyzed mother racked with guilt he
had never been quite able to process
what had happened to cause his mother's
mental state to deteriorate so rapidly
by the time she died she had been
looking at her hands and genuinely
believed they were made of of concrete
she would not move she would not eat she
would not sleep for days she would just
sit staring out of her window he knew he
should have taken her to a doctor but
they just couldn't afford it maybe if he
had this would have all worked out
differently Robert would think about it
hour after hour he would sit down in the
armchair in the corner of his room and
Ponder what had happened it was
difficult to keep track of time living
in the basement there were no windows no
daylight at all but he didn't think he
had been sitting there for very long
when he noticed the skin on his hands
starting to turn gray without Panic he
slowly lifted his hands to his eyes and
inspected what was happening his fingers
down to about halfway through his palms
were dry and solid he could move them
just about but it took a normal effort
and he could see cracks running along
the back of the concrete when he did so
he decided not to he wouldn't say he
felt calm exactly maybe disconnected he
didn't feel particularly hungry he
didn't feel particularly tired in fact
he didn't feel much at all his concrete
limbs were only a passing curiosity to
him as he sat in his chair very
occasionally he would get up to put on a
record on his record player then return
to his seat and stare at the wall that
would be every couple of months at most
the rest of the time he would just sit
there one day he noticed in a vague
corner of his mind that the ground was
shaking and dust was filling the room
The Ripping sound of dynamite and the
heavy Stone just above his head told him
that the apartment block towering over
him had fallen down and almost come
through his ceiling Robert just sat
there unconcerned another day some
indeterminate time later a group of
Builders came in dressed in Peculiar
futuristic clothing with bright yellow
hats and reflective vests they seemed
rather startled to see him though in
truth he had little care for seeing them
what did perturb him was when a group of
people claiming to be Agents from the
foundation came into his room and
carried him out he didn't like the noise
didn't like the change if he wanted to
move he would move not that he could of
course he was now entirely made of
concrete but that was beside the point
these people put him in the back of a
van and drove him across half of the
United States they wheeled him through
brightly lit rooms and into a disgusting
modern white box they had done the
courtesy of bringing his chair along and
found a new record player for him with a
whole selection of album lining a shelf
on the wall he would have appreciated it
and said thank you to them but he didn't
really care he wasn't present at all
this was of course due to the fact that
he was made of concrete by this point
however once he was sat in his chair and
took in the sight in front of him Robert
Chadford felt a dull Panic rising in his
chest they placed him at a window just
like he'd placed his dying mother in
front of a window he tried to clench his
jaw tried to move his hands tried to cry
out in fear and pain but he couldn't he
was paralyzed the smell of smoke filled
his chest choking him torturing him as
the memories of his burning household
raged in his mind he tried to scream he
tried to fight he tried to do anything
other than just sit there but it was far
too late for any of that good afternoon
Mr chatford the researcher said busying
herself and putting on another album for
him to listen to is there anything I can
do for you sir anything I can do to make
you more comfortable the concrete man
said nothing the researcher patted him
on the back of his hand made of concrete
indeed looks just like regular skin to
me Mr Chadford I do wonder what's going
on inside that head of yours on her way
out of the room she glanced at his view
from the window beautiful weather
outside today isn't it scorching even in
1914 an arch Duke of Austria Hungary was
shot by a Serbian nationalist this led
after a series of Nations signing
treaties with other nations to one of
the bloodiest conflicts ever fought a
war that was unlike any that had been
and fought at the time trench combat mud
and sandbags newer deadlier advancements
in the art of warfare vile incurable and
fatal diseases and months upon months of
Misery all while trapped in dark dank
dugouts the Great War the first world
war it's gone by many names since its
ceasefire in 1918 and while there aren't
many left of the generation that
remembers it there are still plenty of
scars left on the world that remind us
of the the horrors but there's one that
seems to be keeping those wounds fresh
reminding us that war is indeed hell as
that rough Beast slouches towards its
destination this is SCP
2574 what appears from the outset to be
nothing more than a stone sculpture of a
lion comprised of sandstone and living
tissue standing at around 12 M tall SCP
2574 is much more than a mere statue in
fact it is a living creature after all
this is the SCP Foundation we're talking
about here where inanimate objects are
rarely inanimate at all or will at least
possess some form of anomalous
properties setting apart anything
ordinary and thus drawing the interest
of the foundation SCP 2574 is similar in
that regard and not just for being a
living statue creature for one the
anomaly is capable of movement albeit at
a gradual rate that only progresses
between 3 and 5 km per day attempts by
the foundation to slow or halt the
movement of SCP 2574 have been so far
unsuccessful as it seems that any
obstacle placed in its path are unable
to deter it this includes both man-made
and naturally occurring obstructions
meaning there is little that can be
deployed to keep SCP
2574 physically contained even if a body
of water is in its path the enti can
swim at a rate of between 2 and 3 km per
day and will normally either crush or
climb over any obstacle on land at the
previous annual budgeting meeting the
top mins of the foundation's accounting
department revealed to an infuriated 05
Council that SCP 2574 had been
responsible for an estimated total of
25.3 million Us in Damages since its
Discovery the second most pressing
matter raised during that presentation
was that 112 deaths and a further 625
injuries the anomaly had also caused
despite pleas from the Ethics Committee
the foundation accountants were still
adamant that the cost of Damages was
more significant now a number of
prevailing questions might be plaguing
you regarding SCP
2574 for one what does this creature
want if it has freedom of movement and
can't be physically obstructed by the
foundation then is it just aimless ly
wandering free and causing want on
destruction or doesn't have a specific
want or goal it seeks to attain and for
another what does an almost 40ft tall
lion have to do with World War I well it
might surprise you to know that SCP 2574
has everything to do with the Great War
literally everything and as for a goal
it has one or rather it has a specific
destination it seems to be gradually
heading towards and if it makes it all
the way there it could spell disaster
for the entire globe in fact it could
plunge us back into one of the most
devastating conflicts the world has ever
seen can you guess which one SCP 2574
possesses a wide array of latent
anomalous effects Beyond its General
functionality and movement above the
Sandstone line creature it is constantly
surrounded by A Flock of around 6,000
Birds of Prey any that find themselves
flying into the path of SCP 2574 are
assimilated into the growing flock
designated as SCP
25741 the mass of birds is fixated on
attacking SCP
2574 swooping low to strike at its
smooth muscle tissue with using their
beaks and Talons this however seems to
do little to deter SCP 2574 from making
progress as the anomaly constantly
regenerates from physical damage it
incurs from SCP 2574 one perhaps the
most notable and noticeable of SCP 2574
anomalous properties is the effect it
has on its surroundings as it progresses
towards its destination the area around
SCP 2574 will undergo a physical
transformation in response to the
presence of the lion this transformation
results in the nearby region temporarily
becoming a World War I era combat zone
the ground below becomes riddled with
trenches carved through the Earth thick
muddy bogs and coiled Razorsharp Nets of
barbed wire litter the area the change
triggered by SCP 2574 is hardly just a
cosmetic one either the foundation have
observed a number of First World War
related manifestations that occur in the
wake of SCP
2574 man-made land masses like trenches
and dugouts will appear nearby the front
lines reappearing after more than a
century Weaponry from the area is also
present following the the arrival of SCP
2574 and this isn't just limited to
Firearms World War I was one of the
earliest large scale conflicts in
history where in both sides deployed
aerial attacks through the use of
biplanes as well as chemical warfare as
a result signs of these can also be
found whenever SCP 2574 is nearby but
again the transformation as CP 2574
brings about is not just limited to
recreating battlefields what some of you
may not know is the Great War did not so
much revolve around a core idealistic
difference between both sides as its
successor did instead the first world
war was a geopolitical grudge match
between large Global superpowers
attempting to make grandio displays of
their amassed military strength the
assassination of Archduke France
Ferdinand of Austria at the hands of a
Serbian extremist group was the Catalyst
that set off a chain reaction of events
that ultimately l led to War as a result
of this SCP 2574 is anomalous influence
also extends to the social and political
state of the areas it enters a country
that the Sandstone leonine entity enters
will suffer a rapid change in its local
populations mentality the ordinary
people living there will start to
experience a great degree of discontent
towards their government while the
ruling powers of said country will
increase its use of force against its
own civilians this effect is more
noticeably potent when SCP 2574
interacts with countries that were
directly involved in the first world war
increasing levels of civil unrest and
discontentment among the population
these are often countered with
worryingly increased levels of police
brutality along with governments
enacting aggressive foreign policies and
sometimes antagonizing other countries
as if they are eager to fight these
effects don't necessarily worsen the
closer SC P 2574 gets to a particular
country but do seem to increase the more
it approaches its predicted destination
and where is that you may ask the
foundation have calculated that based on
SCP 2574 trajectory since its emergence
back in 2012 The Entity is headed for
the city of Saro the capital city of
Bosnia and Herzegovina what possible
reason could SCP 2574 have for wanting
to venture towards this specific Bosnian
City well one cursory glance at the
history of Saro will give you the answer
it's where the assassination of arch
Duke France Ferdinand took place the
event commonly attributed with starting
the first world war the transformative
effects SC SCP 2574 has on its
surroundings began when the leonine
Leviathan first appeared and commenced
its journey toward Saro on December 24th
2012 since then the SCP Foundation has
been closely monitoring the Sandstone
creatures movements and attempting to
log all of the anomalous effects it has
had over the course of making its way
closer to the site of France ferdinand's
assassination over 5,000 km away to the
east of kazakhstan's capital aana SCP
2574 caused an unusual World War I
anomalous effect any written works
published in either Russian or kazak
began to randomly feature passages from
Irish poet WB Yates these extracts from
his body of work range from single
sentences to entire poems being featured
in other writers Publications regardless
of author or genre Yates for anyone
unfamiliar was widely considered one of
the greatest Poets of the 20th century
however unlike the authors of numerous
poems and songs to come out of the first
world war WB Yates was never directly
involved in the conflict itself and
didn't write much about it barring a few
notable exceptions but more on him in a
moment when SCP 2574 approached Russia
things started to escalate clouds of
deadly chlorine gas an early World War I
chemical weapon began forming in rural
areas throughout Europe that couldn't be
dispersed for days at a time as soon as
the Towering anomaly got close enough
Russian military forces began launching
a series of drone strikes and aerial
bombardments targeting SCP 2574 War when
these attacks failed tensions mounted
with bordering countries the situation
only getting worse when it was
discovered through an intelligence leak
that Russia was planning a nuclear
strike against the creature a move that
likely could have spelled disaster for
the neighboring countries SCP 2574 of
course sustained no damage and continued
on its course given that they couldn't
physically contain SCP
2574 the foundation was forced to think
outside of the B when it came to coming
up with some kind of solution there were
already too many eyewitnesses aware of
the leonine leviathan's existence to
consider administering amnestics even on
a large scale the fact was too many
people already knew about SCP 2574 and
would make such a move pointless the
best that the foundation could do to
combat if not counteract the effects of
SCP 2574 was to work directly with
governments affected by the creatures
World War I transform formative effects
to try and repair the damage left in the
anomaly's wake and ease the tension and
violence it caused it became the
foundation's job to deter any country
planning an armed military response to
the presence of SCP
2574 as any such strike would endanger
both their military and civilian
populations while causing no damage to
the anomaly in the interest of trying to
solve the problems posed by SCP 2574
rever ing parts of Europe to hellish
First World War era battlefields the
foundation made a rare agreement to
collaborate with another large
organization specializing in the
anomalous the global occult Coalition
working directly with the GOC their goal
was to create a large-scale mimetic
countermeasure that would effectively
reset the toll SCP 2574 had exacted on
global Psychology by altering people's
temperaments and creating mass political
unrest as it progressed towards the
Bosnian Capital however given the tense
history between the SCP Foundation and
the global occult Coalition their
attempts at creating a mimetic
countermeasure are still ongoing since
neither group wants the other to engage
them in fullscale mtic Warfare as such
the proposed countermeasure will consist
of two parts with neither organization
being able to replicate the others half
meanwhile SCP 2574 progress across
Europe was responsible for number of
other significant changes physically
socially and politically recreating the
conditions of the first world war
poppies a flower that has since become
synonymous with the remembrance of the
conflict began to grow in regions within
Russia where they wouldn't naturally
occur this included within Urban
locations the red flowers sprouting in
and around buildings as a result of such
a high-profile anomaly causing such
widespread unrest to spread a number of
religious cult centered around SCP 2574
began to form while the living
descendants of World War I veterans
began suffering from Vivid
hallucinations that depicted their
ancestors firsthand experience of the
fighting these Cults began to amass more
and more of those affected by SCP
2574 the SCP Foundation was able to
observe some of the sermons delivered by
these religious cults who appeared to
view the public appearances of SCP
2574 as signs of an impending apocalypse
come to us and embrace your salvation
one cult leader exclaimed in a sermon
discover the words of the Prophet Yates
who spoke this sacred truth that all of
history is a spiral and that we have
spiraled outwards towards chaos learn
the true nature of the second coming it
appeared that some of these Cults viewed
the Poetry of wb8 as prophetic in
regards to scp2 574 they would often
reference the second coming which
interestingly was the name of one of his
poems written in the aftermath of World
War I yates's the second coming refers
to a rough Beast slouching towards
Bethlehem the SCP Foundation has since
uncovered some erratic writings made by
the poet before his death that allude to
Bethlehem despite no record existing of
him ever traveling there it is believed
that Yates somehow figured out what SCP
25 74 was and that The Closer it gets to
its destination the more civilization
will spiral further out of control
towards total allc consuming chaos
further research by the foundation also
uncovered a testimony made by gabilo
princip the Serbian man responsible for
assassinating Arch duuk France Ferdinand
of Austria and thus sparking the first
world war prin seems to have had had
some knowledge about SCP
2574 and apparently killed the the arch
duuke as a way to begin the creatures
journey in order to make Society more
chaotic with SCP 2574 progressing
worryingly closer to the site of France
ferdinand's assassination further chaos
rapidly began to spread anarchic
sentiments took hold of most of Europe
leading to an increased rate of violent
encounters between civilians and police
in many countries including Ireland
France Great Britain and Italy with a
number of these experiencing widespread
rioting in their major population
centers any government or political
party compelled by SCP 2574 to openly
exous the same Anarchist sentiments were
soon seeing a rapid increase in their
public approval gaining more popularity
in polls than their opposition as a
result of these heightened tensions
between the public and the government of
their countries assassination attempts
of politicians saw an alarming increase
of around
60% SCP 25 74 caused countries that had
existing hostile relations to engage in
armed skirmishes at their borders with
at least one of these battles occurring
every 2 weeks and each time threatening
to spark a much larger scale conflict
thanks to the anomalies effects the
international tensions dissolving
alliances between countries and Adoption
of nationalism which were all factors
leading to the start of the Great War
were beginning to rapidly spread once
again by the time SCP 2574 was around
550 km from Saro people began
experiencing injuries common among
soldiers during World War I many
patients would die during surgery only
for their bodies to disappear shortly
afterwards conflict erupt between
Ireland and England and as SCP 2574
entered Bosnia and Herzegovina many
began to report suffering intense dreams
about the anomaly a number of these
reports seem to state that SCP 2574 was
attempting to communicate with them and
multiple websites began logging the
Sandstone Lion's appearance in their
dreams and things will only get worse
the closer SCP 2574 gets to Saro SCP
2574 contains the raw energy of World
War I one of the most catastrophic
events in human history a global
conflict with a death toll in the tens
of millions the SCP Foundation estimates
it'll reach the site of France Ferd
assassination within a month and from
that point given the effect it's had on
the rest of Europe there's only one
likely outcome when that rough Beast
slouches towards its ultimate
destination War screams filled the cold
night air drowned out by the panicked
gunshots and the vicious growl of
something inhuman a being from who knows
where a creature that the agents
surrounding it were woefully
underprepared to capture General mcoy
barks at the soldiers to concentrate
their fire on the Beast his men those
who hadn't already fallen turned and
trained their guns on the creature
squeezing their trigger fingers bullets
spewed out of their weapons a hail of
gunfire that sped towards their target
only to miss as it suddenly vanished
from the spot it had been standing only
a split second earlier their bullets
passed through the thin air left in its
wake shredding several nearby trees one
of the men threw his gun to the ground
turned heel and sprinted away as fast as
he could he hadn't known what he was
signing on for when he was recruited by
a shadowy upand cominging organization
he' just been flattered to be headhunted
for his combat skill and agreed to be
one of the new organization's first
field agents if he'd known it would
result in him facing off against a demon
near a rural road in Guatemala and he
would have stayed in the regular
military the fleeing agent suddenly
stopped in his tracks instantly feeling
sick it was the most Indescribable type
of sickness worse than any he had ever
felt in his entire life he dropped to
the ground his pants from running away
replaced with heaves as his entire body
seemed to have suddenly turned against
him his head was burning at first he
thought he'd run too fast too quickly
and was overheating underneath his
military fatigues and helmet but he was
no slouch recruited for being in Peak
Physical conditions such as he was never
in his life had the agent ever felt this
bad the heat from his forehead was
unbearable a fever running rampant as
its Vision began to blur everything was
spinning that unsettling imbalance that
comes with severe nausea rapidly taking
hold of the Fallen agent then the
monster came back through unfocused eyes
he looked up at The Tall featureless
Face of the creature as it looked down
at him he was helpless hurling and
shuttering barely able to stand if
someone had brought a guer counter with
them it would be ticking loudly and
frequently if they held it near the
agent and that somehow was about to be
the least of his problems the creature
opened up its mouth the only facial
feature that occupied its head past its
few remaining teeth was a Milky blue orb
the same thing that had been visible
right before the creature itself wasn't
as the agent from his place on the
ground caught sight of the pale eyeball
in the monster throat something started
pulling his body in on itself it was
like falling except gravity was acting
on different parts of his body at
different speeds at different times his
arms and legs folded inwards towards his
Center of mass making the agent scream
out in pain as his body collapsed he
folded into himself like origami Peace
by agonizing peace until there was
nothing left hearing the man's scream
General mcoy and the others broke
through the tree line flashlight beams
Illuminating the creature the general
yelled again for his man to shoot it
trying to hide his fear with animal rage
it snarled at them as they raised their
guns once more then leaped towards them
ready for another kill in the years to
come the successors to these men and
their fallen colleagues would be the
world's foremost experts in situations
like this the capture and containment of
anomalies would one day be a more
streamlined process rather than the
blood bath currently unfolding in the
small guat in town dying at the hands of
what locals had thought to be a demon
were some of the earliest precursors to
the SCP Foundation humble beginnings
indeed the creature was eventually
captured by the early precursor version
of what would one day be the SCP
Foundation at this time in their history
the organization had far fewer resources
and reach than they would one day have
at their disposal they didn't even have
the SCP numerical designation system
that has since become synonymous with
the organization and the various
anomalies they keep contained as a
result this so-called demon was
originally classified as number
a-001 however it would later be known as
SCP 001 or one of the anomalies to share
that designation at least SCP 001 itself
was an abnormally thin humanoid creature
with a gray brown skin its emaciated
bone and muscle structure didn't match
any known species
it sported dark claws at the tips of its
arms with both legs terminating in
similar sharp black points rather than
Paws or feet most striking was its face
or rather its lack of one the creature's
head was spherical with a lipless mouth
reaching halfway around its
circumference within was a ma of 21
teeth each spaced randomly apart and
either chipped broken or rotting it
possessed one eye or what was at least
believed to be an eye eye in the form of
a large milky blue sphere in its throat
with no pupil or Iris as was discovered
in initial testing by Dr Herman ker For
Whom the ubiquitous ker class
designation was named SCP 001 was able
to create micro singularities using its
single milky blue eye it could deploy
these as a means of teleporting itself
out of Harm's Way or for offensive
attacks that could cause a human body to
collapse in on itself these s
singularities often also produced The
Nasty side effect of emitting lethal
amounts of deadly radiation that could
not only cause damage to the surrounding
area but also would fatally poison
anyone nearby as a result It is believed
one of these micro singularities was
responsible for the untimely death of Dr
ker however Ker's Research into SCP 001
was at least able to produce solutions
for keeping it contained it was
discovered that SCP 001 could not
teleport through lead and would display
signs of extreme sickness and fear when
exposed to high levels of heat and
humidity or bright flashing lights
strobe lights were used to induce this
sicken State and in this state the
creature was unable to form harmful
singularities Dr Ker's death also
ushered in the affir mention creation of
the ker class designation for anomalous
creatures or artifacts that are
extraordinarily tough to keep safely
contained in fact if any of this account
is to be believed the very Discovery and
capture of SCP 001 was the impetus for
the entire SCP foundation's approach to
researching and containing anomalies in
the days before the likes of Dr krai or
Dr cleff before Infamous anomalies such
as SCP 682 the hardto destroy reptile or
scp096 the shy guy were even known about
things were well pretty uneventful for
the newly formed Foundation
as you can probably imagine but none
exemplified this better than Harold
woodu an uninteresting man living in
uneventful life or as uneventful as one
could get when their job was working for
the foundation during this crucial
period of the SCP foundation's early
history as the anomalous research and
containment organization was taking its
first steps towards protecting the
people of the world Harold was Finding
himself bored already with his work
Harold was a senior archist at a small
site in sloths pit Wisconsin this was
before the foundation had secret
facilities situated all over the world
and even the infamous site 19 as it is
today had yet to be established for now
it was known only as adrx -9 the oldest
Foundation site on record and records
were herold's entire working life he was
in charge of maintaining the earliest
reports of anomalous activity and the
inner workings of the fledgling
Foundation One Day Harold received a
letter from adrx 19 unfamiliar with the
designation he ran a check through the
records and discovered that the site had
been established before the foundation
had even gotten its name the letter
contained an update for the senior
archist having grown obsolete in its own
age adrx 19 was being closed for Good
and that meant all of the anomalous
entities and objects stored there would
soon be shipped off to be stored
elsewhere the first package arrived at
the site Harold was stationed at not
long after he walked briskly out to meet
the delivery officer as he wheeled the
large wooden crate through the bay doors
it didn't take the archist long to
realize what exactly he had now been
given the ownership of and charged with
protecting the crate even came complete
with relevant case files to accompany it
stamped on one side of the box was a
series of numbers and letters that
shocked Harold when he read them SCP 001
he exchanged a confused look with the
man who had delivered the anomaly who
just laughed when he saw Harold's
expression
you in here he asked SCP 001 is dead the
creature's death had come on the heel of
a number of significant changes made by
the foundation hups these decisions were
ultimately both the direct result of the
encounter with SCP 001 in Guatemala were
also changes that would ultimately shape
the foundation into its modern iteration
the first of these was the introduction
of the numerical designation system
providing each anomaly with an SCP
number formerly designated as is number
8624 3
a-001 the creature that was captured and
researched by Dr ker was announced to be
reclassified as SCP 01- Cog originally
the number attached to each SCP denoted
the order in which they were encountered
by the foundation however the overseer
Council believed this posed a security
risk offering too much information about
their operations to any potential
adversaries as a result the use of SCP
001 designation started started to be
applied in a slightly different way a
number of anomalies were then grouped
Under the Umbrella designation of SCP
001 some of these were real anomalies
and amongst the earliest that the
foundation encountered others were
entirely fake and used as a cover for
the real SCP
001 nobody not even within the
foundation itself was ever told exactly
how many files fell under the SCP 001
umbrella or indeed which was the real
one the an IES included the gate
Guardian a towering Colossus of pure
energy wielding a flaming sword believed
to be the biblical Angel guarding the
Garden of Eden the Scarlet King an
extradimensional Tyrant that longs to
conquer our reality a group of 36
individuals capable of neutralizing
anomalies even the SCP Foundation itself
is considered one potential SCP 001 and
among them is also the creature from
Guatemala otherwise known as the
Prototype the same creature whose
inhuman bones were now in a box before
Herold the senior archivist had long
heard legends about what exactly as SCP
001 might be it was a question often
whispered among Foundation staff who
were curious what the first anomaly
might be but didn't have the security
clearance to know the truth rumors
spread that SCP 001 was more powerful
than any other anomalies in containment
that the capture or discovery of it was
either the reason for the foundation
ever forming or it was one of their
greatest failures meant to be kept their
closest guarded secret something far too
terrible to comprehend you might think
that now being presented with an answer
would give Herold relief So Many Wonders
and haunting queries about SCP 001 were
put to rest but instead as he opened up
the wooden crate and looked at the pile
of strange bones inside it had the
opposite effect none of it was the
interesting answer that Harold and many
others had hoped for if anything it was
a huge disappointment all that
speculation surrounding the mystery of
SCP 001 what it was where it had come
from why it was kept so secret was this
the answer was just the first thing that
the SCP Foundation had put into a box
according to the foundation's own
internal reports the Prototype monster
had been found lying still in its
containment chamber during a routine
inspection it wasn't moving at all even
armed guards couldn't get a reaction
from the creature the anomaly wasn't
breathing its heart having slowed to a
stop little was known about the
creature's biology but even then nothing
could be done to resuscitate it as far
as anyone could tell the anomaly known
as SCP 01- Cog had died of old age after
exhibiting movement that got gradually
slower and weaker and even less hostile
Behavior over the course of the previous
decade since its initial capture but yet
Harold was still dissatisfied with the
knowledge that this was SCP 001 it
became fixated on the case surrounding
it studying the files he was charged
with moving to storage he learned of the
few ways the creatures Discovery had
influence the early foundation for
example the death of Dr ker being the
reason for the use of ker class in their
terminology still that didn't feel
nearly as important as Herold and others
had speculated that SCP 001 would be
there had to be something more to it and
for weeks following the arrival of the
creature's bones Harold could not stop
thinking about it something about all
this didn't sit right with him the
secrecy that the foundation shrouded SCP
001 and seemed like overkill for just a
monster the organization I had seen far
worse than the likes of the prototype in
the many years since at the time perhaps
it had seemed like the most dangerous
anomaly the foundation had encountered
if it really was the first then
technically at that time it would have
been the most dangerous if there were no
others to compare it to one night Harold
ventured into the archive and opened up
the box contain raining the creature's
bones using a crowbar he had to know had
to understand exactly what was so
important about this being cracking the
wooden crate open he removed the skull
to examine it the foundation hadn't even
had a chance to figure out what exactly
the creature was or where it had
originated from all they knew was it
could produce micro singularities and
lethal doses of radiation beyond that
the only other details came from the
Guatemalan locals who had encountered it
first they had called it a demon perhaps
it was the foundation would never know
for certain and it seemed to Harold that
they didn't care to know now that SCP
001 was dead and didn't seem to care
much before then either they were more
than happy to just discard it he
couldn't shake the feeling that there
was meant to be something important
about the creature Herold couldn't help
it The Whispers surrounding SCP 00001
all indicated it was meant to be
something more significant than a cast
aside pile of bones Bones the
underwhelming reality he was being
presented with didn't match the idea of
SCP 001 Harold examined the skull
closely in his hands turning it around
and around as he tried to maybe spot
something some important detail that
everyone else in the foundation had
failed to notice were some of the puzzle
that would explain what was so important
about this creature and yet the more he
looked the less he learned Alas poor SCP
001 he settle loud paraphrasing Hamlet
of course what Harold didn't know didn't
possess the clearance to know was that
this wasn't the only
scp1 maybe the foundation's lack of
interest in the creatures remains was
all part of their plan to keep the real
scp1 a secret where Harold only saw a
box of Bones and a disappointing answer
to so many burning questions the SCP
Foundation saw their system working
exactly as intended a giant monstrous
craba likee claw closes around the
throat of an unimaginably huge eel-like
Beast the beast's terrible writhing
tentacles wrap around and latch onto the
immense crustation and then the
high-intensity beams of gamma radiation
start flying all the while Legions of
skinless Centaur swim in the waters
around them relishing the violence and
in the middle a lone boat the scps
myther maned by a team of mobile task
force operatives that does all it can
just to survive there are those who
consider outer space to be the ultimate
achievement in Exploration the one place
that explorers have yet to chart and
understand however some of the murkiest
Mysteries in the universe are on our own
Planet deep down at the bottom of the
ocean 95% of the deep ocean remains
completely unexplored and the little
glimpses we have gotten paint a picture
of something something truly alien giant
squids organisms that can breathe
nitrogen luminescent predatory fish and
sharks as old as the Earth itself even
the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to fully grasp the depth of the ocean
and the strange beings that dwell there
one of the most unusual aquatic findings
in the history of the foundation is that
of SCP
3700 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North Sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters of SCP 3700 designated SCP
37001 and SCP 3700 D2 interactions
between these two entities are
responsible for the anomalous changes to
the meteorological and geological
conditions in the area SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinoxes of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep SCP 37001 is an arthropod
bearing an a resemblance to the European
Lobster only much much bigger measuring
6 km in length the creature is green
with a mix of blue yellow pink and red
markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entities four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stocks anyone who gets closer enough to
observe the creature's carapace in
detail will notice scars cracks and
small holes indicating years and years
of damage SCP 37001 has several
anomalous qualities in addition to its
size in a fight it is able to strike
with its appendages and produce
cavitation bubbles with a force greater
than several tons of Dynamite two of the
entities eyes are capable of blasting
concentrated gamma radiation at a chosen
Target the creature has the ability to
impact the weather around it dispersing
storms that impede its ability to move
with ease and can reach speeds up to 100
km an hour in spite of its immense power
SCP
37001 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP 3700 D2 speaking of SCP 3700 D2 it
is a 32 km long entity resembling a
pelican eel in in all aspects except for
its massive size and the 13 appendages
that encircle the middle section of its
body these appendages which tuck inside
its body when not in use are similar to
the tentacles of an octopus complete
with suckers the majority of the
entity's body consists of a seny tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated 3 km
deep its flesh is black and it has white
purple and red bioluminescent lines in
the shape of a man's face on either side
of its torso SCP 3700 d2's anomalous
properties include the ability to invoke
storms with the severity of category 5
hurricanes and the ability to produce
whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150 M so that it can rip them
apart it is also able to produce high
energy sound waves as well as blue fire
which it emits from its esophagus when
the two entities interact it results in
an epic struggle as each begins attempts
to destroy or subdue the other when one
is Victorious immediate changes to the
area follow when SCP 37001 wins the
storms and harsh weather in the area
will immediately calm and an era of
fertility and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the Islands nearby increase
threefold and the crop yield doubles the
ocean itself becomes increasingly active
and the erosion rates of the archipelago
Shores increase fivefold when SCP 3700-3
wins however the weather conditions
become dangerous with raging hurricanes
rapidly fluctuating temperatures and
constantly changing Storm fronts that
cause destruction of buildings and loss
of life naturally this renders any Ocean
Travel in the area extremely difficult
or even impossible aquatic food sources
are driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water log soil and lack
of sunlight all the while SCP 37002
swims throughout the area praying on
unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until SCP 37001 manifests to
challenge it again SCP 37002 will also
regurgitate instances of SCP
3456 though how or why this is possible
is unknown for those unfamiliar with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless
three-toed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest in their home
Waters SCP
37001 and 2 cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about SCP 3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications SCP 37-1 has
been implanted with donovian Hollow
projectors which disguise it as a pod of
humpback whales if SCP 37001 encounters
SCP
37002 Delta 7 man gauge protocol winter
Maelstrom this consists of Destroyers
deploying Harpoon based anchors into SCP
3700 d2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target The Entity until SCP 37001 is
able to subdue it if this does not prove
effective and SCP
37002 cannot be contained then the task
force will Implement protocol tumult at
this point Naval and civilian crafts in
the area must be evacuated trade and
Ferry routes to the archipelagos must be
rerouted for at least 6 months there
will be constant aerial and Naval
engagement with SCP 3700 D2 and constant
monitoring for the reappearance of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20th 2017
a pair of SCP Foundation owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Teran arrived at a point between the
orne Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 M away from the ship's
anchor points the water began to emit
intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the end
entity as the ships caught up to the
entity it raised two of its claws into
the air clicking them together in a
friendly greeting the Delta 7 ships
followed the entity along its usual
swimming path for 30 minutes and during
this time all was peaceful but this
peace did not endure for long the tide
began to change literally as large black
wall clouds formed overhead the winds
picked up and the waves churned
violently in response as CP 3700 -1
raised its claws overhead waving them in
a circular motion and parting the clouds
above it and Delta 7 but this effort
took a lot out of the creature and after
30 seconds its antenna began to droop
and it lowered its claws still the hole
in the clouds remained allowing a spot
of sunshine to break through and beam
down on the foundation vessels 600 M
ahead the ocean waters began to rage and
froth spraying foam and surf into the
air SCP 37002 burst from beneath the
surface its head pointed upward it
continued to rise until the tops of its
tentacles could be seen just above the
water then stopped to bend its torso and
turn its head horizontally its jaw
unhinged exposing rows upon rows of
serrated teeth the Beast leted out a
mighty Roar accompanied by a stream of
blue flame at the sight of its rival SCP
37001 Dove beneath the surface surf
disappearing from view the scps mither
ordered the rest of the vessels to
engage protocol winter Maelstrom delta7
scattered out from SCP 3700 d1's point
of submersion and all 13 destroyers
fired their harpoons at SCP 3700 D2
embedding themselves in the entity's
head naturally this enraged the creature
and it began to Roar and whale spinning
its lower body vigorously enough to
generate a Whirlpool the Cruisers open
fire with a combination of L cannons and
conventional Weaponry in order to
distract The Entity as the Destroyers
pulled their Harpoon lines ta dragging
its head in a continuous Circle while
this was taking place the battleships
got into position and prepared to fire
on the myther Mark 3 2 1 fire the first
broadside barrage collided with SCP 3700
D2 and it grunted in pain thrashing back
and forth before opening its mouth and
spewing an instance of SCP 3456 into the
water as soon as it hit the water the
eoin monster began to cut through at a
pace of 50 km an hour making its way
toward the Destroyers particularly the
scps selki the skki attempted to
retarget its weapons and prevent the
creature from reaching it but the
monster moved too quickly for the skki
to adjust the skki was lifted out of the
water by the creature as crew members
desperately clung to the railings and
their Weaponry as the crew cowered tried
to fend off the creature it reach for
them trying to pull them from the ship
while the sky was occupied SCP 37-2 was
able to attack again blasting another
ship with a stream of blue fire a loud
crack rang out from across the sea as
the sky dropped back into the water the
SCP 3456 instant shrieking in pain SCP
3700 D1 burst through the surface
striking the creature with its Club
likee limbs each blow emitting another
loud crack the third blow tore the
instance in half sending its human torso
kening through the air and pass the scps
mither freed from its attack the Suki
moved full steam ahead pulling the
Harpoon line Tau again and dragging SCP
37002 out of its path several silky crew
members were thrown overboard during the
struggle and as they struggled to keep
their heads above water SCP 3700 D1
scooped them up placing them onto the
deck of a nearby destroyer and out of
Harm's Way with the crew members rescued
SC SCP 37001 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the constant
barrage of cannon fire on SCP 37002 was
beginning to take its toll and the
mither ordered the fleet to quote brace
for the killing blow as if responding to
the mither's call SCP 37001 shot several
concentrated blasts of of gamma
radiation at its foe leaving large holes
in the creature in their wake SCP 37002
screamed flailing so hard that it
snapped the Harpoon lines and created
waves large enough to push the vessels
backward with its new found freom SCP
3700 D2 impaled SCP 37001 through the
midsection with its Barbed tip of its
tail lifting it up and out of the water
with the force of the blow SCP 37001 Des
ly tried to free itself attacking the
tail with its Club likee limbs but the
fight was in vain and after a moment all
movement stopped SCP 3700 D1 was for at
least the duration of this manifestation
dead SCP 300-2 tossed the corpse into
the water flinging it past Delta 7 where
it crashed into the water and sank down
into the deps below at this point Delta
7 was ordered to initiate protocol
tumult the Delta 7 vessels turned away
from SCP
37002 and prepared to evacuate the area
one of the ships the scps Str Beast
slowed behind the rest of the fleet
emitting concerning amounts of smoke
before coming to a stop meanwhile the
enraged and emboldened SCP
37002 expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened Stony Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SCP
37002 as the crew looked on in helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity gaping ma suddenly
SCP 37001 exploded from beneath the
surface of the water leaping between the
ship and SCP 3700 D2 cutting the
tentacle in half and freeing the sty
beast from its grip SCP 3700 -2 shrieked
before closing its jaws and biting down
on SCP
37001 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop SCP 3700 D2 from continuing to
produce its Whirlpool another tentacle
emerged from the water pulling at SCP
3700 d1's legs and ripping them from its
body but SCP 37001 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning SCP 37002 with its
Club likee limbs from inside of its
mouth all at once SCP 3700 d2's lower
jaw was torn out of place dropping into
the water with SCP 3700 D1 still inside
SCP 3700 D2 thrashed fuly growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after 5 minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to to
the side of the battle to investigate
and saw that neither entity was moving
and both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface where SCP
37001 had just been the wall clouds
overhead dispersed leaving standard
cumon nimbus clouds in their place the
waters themselves remained choppy unsure
of how to proceed the scps mither sent a
radio transmission to command uh this is
Delta 7 to command we read you Delta 7
command replied we have a bit of a
situation go ahead Delta 7 SCP
37001 and two are both down command was
silent for 10 seconds utterly baffled by
the information please repeat Delta 7
again the myther said SCP 3700 D1 and
two are both down command ordered the
myther to standby 3 minutes of radio
silence later communication resumed as
they asked are either entities effects
active ah negative command is there any
trace of either entity also negative it
appears the anomaly has been neutralized
Delta 7 is to return to base for debrief
following any recovery efforts with
their next steps clear Delta 7 attached
the sty bees to several tugboats
preparing to pull the vessel to safety
but there was one more surprise waiting
the scps myther began picking up unusual
levels of gamma radiation as well as a
sonar contact at a depth of 3 km they
called command requesting permission to
deploy submersibles for exploration
purposes one minute of Silence followed
as the command arrived at a decision
request denied return to base for
debriefing and so Delta 7 began to
evacuate the area once more steaming in
the opposite direction of the battle
over the next 5 minutes CCTV cameras on
the vessels picked up and un unusual
sight as the gamma radiation levels
continued to increase the ocean
turbulence also worsened tossing smaller
vessels and nearly causing them to
capsize then all of a sudden the water
stilled and four large yellow orbs
appeared below the surface approximately
300 M from Delta 7 they lingered there
for 2 minutes before Vanishing afterward
a new sonar contact was detected 5 km
deep directly beneath the task force
command we've lost the signal from the
previous contact and are no longer
detecting gamma radiation uh we're
detecting new contact 5 km deep large
and metallic after further deliberation
command responded Delta 7 you are
authorized to deploy submersibles for
exploration purposes be advis should SCP
37002 manifest exploration teams are to
be considered lost and you are to return
to base the consequences of this
incident as well as what else might be
lurking down in the depths beneath SCP
3700 are still unknown nobody should
ever have to find out what a human body
smells like especially as it's being
eaten Sally clasped both hands over her
face trying desperately to block out the
smell and to trap in her nervous
breathing she couldn't bring herself to
look every bone in her body wanted to
take off running through the forest back
out onto the Interstate to try and find
some help but there was nothing she
could do she could never outrun that
thing it was too fast too Savage even if
she could convince someone on the
highway to pull over and help her they
would just tell her she was going crazy
maybe she was then the smell of her
husband's body drifted over to her on
the Wind as the crunching sound of
inhuman Jaws filled the air Panic said
in then silence she couldn't hear or
anything not even a whisper in the trees
had she done it had she survived that's
when a red sneaker stepped out from
behind the tree and Sally stared into
the eyes of the blood spattered Hedgehog
now Sally had never been a gamer growing
up sure she played a little bit of Mario
Kart and had a few nintend dogs back in
the day but the word gamer just wasn't
for her however love conquers all and
when she found the man of her dream she
decided that it would be worth at least
giving some of his Hobbies a go they
started off nice and easy playing a bit
of stardew Valley Minecraft and maybe
some overcooked here and there but
before long the pair of them were
sitting down every day after work
headsets on and controllers in hand
ready to dive into the latest Adventure
just recently the couple had gotten into
Retro games going back and playing
Classics like battle toads and Streets
of Rage the challenge was addictive so
when her husband John came home with a
copy of an unmarked NES game Sally was
intrigued to say the least Jon explained
that he had found it listed on eBay
under a very suspicious account he had
gone to pick up the game after work that
day expecting to be greeted by the
smiling face of the seller instead he
found a blank gray cartridge and a very
brief manual wrapped together with an
elastic band on a street corner the
seller had listed it for virtually
nothing and based on the description
seemed very eager to get rid of the game
for some reason so eager that he must
not have wanted to stick around to even
hand it over Sally already bored with
this backstory snatched the manual up
and read the title of the game Professor
Gould's terrifying horror challenge
there was no artwork no branding no
publisher no stickers nothing to
differentiate this game from being just
a blank cartridge as far as Sally knew
it could have been a virus some kind of
malware game designed to Brick their NES
but the words horror and Challenge from
the title sold her she blew on the pins
in the cartridge and slotted it into
place in the NES a black screen appeared
with nothing on it but two options
single player or two-player Sally
uncoiled a second controller and handed
it to John with a grin you ready Sally
hit two-player and a new screen came up
are the people holding the controllers
the people who want to play the game yes
or no Sally hit yes a shrill beep filled
the room high-pitched and Grading on
their ears Jon immediately grabbed for
the remote and turned the volume down on
the TV but the beep just kept going the
screen was a bright red filling the room
with an unnatural bloody light Jon tried
to hit the off button on the remote but
the TV stayed red and the beeping sound
continued filling their tiny apartment
getting up and rushing over to the TV
johon tried to unplug it but it was no
use the beeping noise and the red screen
persisted he looked back at his wife in
confusion but she was looking somewhere
else entirely there was a rat in the
corner of the room with muddled fur
bloated flesh and cracked teeth it
stared right into Sally's eyes
salivating without a moment's hesitation
she leaped up onto the couch and
screamed but instead of running away the
rat slowly crept forward looking almost
as if it was smiling then a second one
appeared crawling out from behind the
couch followed by a third in the doorway
and a fourth beneath the TV dozens of
rats filled the room swarming in from
all directions climbing over one another
in a desperate attempt to get into the
tiny apartment to get to Sally and John
Sally clambered onto the couch with her
laptop and tried to kick away any of the
rats clambering up onto to the furniture
but it was no use for every rat she
kicked away another one appeared until
soon they were climbing their way up
Jon's jeans their sharp little claws
digging into his flesh the rats tore at
Sally's clothes climbing over one
another desperately heading towards her
mouth trying to burrow their way in
hairy bodies filled her vision and the
stench of disease made her gag seizing
an opportunity a rat tried to clamber
through her open Jaws she felt its Tiny
Paws scrabbling at her tongue with tears
filling her eyes she took one fleeting
look at the man she loved and noticed
something behind him a giant Yellow
bottle with the words rat poison stamped
into the side was sitting precariously
on top of their cabinet half stumbling
half swimming Sally pushed her way
through the throng of rats filling their
apartment and desperately grabbed the
bottle from on top of the cabinet
throwing the rats off her hands she
managed to unscrew the lid held the the
bottle High over her head and poured the
thick stinking liquid all over the swarm
of rats threatening to engulf her the
chorus of death filled the room whether
it was the sound of the rats dying or
their bodies being evaporated by the
poison she couldn't tell all she could
do was push through to try and find her
husband and save him too and
miraculously within just a few seconds
all of the rats had disappeared the room
was empty the same as it had always been
even the big yellow bottle was gone from
her hand all she could do was stare at
JN as he stared back at her as the words
level one complete appeared above their
heads welcome to SCP
1315 the most visceral most real and
most dangerous horror game you will ever
have The Misfortune of playing it's not
too late to back out at the menu screen
when you select how many players you
want it's it's not even too late at the
confirmation screen but once you're in
the game there's no turning back either
you beat the game or you die trying
beating this game is no easy feat a copy
of SCP 1315 has been in Foundation
containment since 1986 but in all of
that time only one d-class personnel has
managed to make it to level 33 it is not
known how many levels there are but
there is theoretically a final boss the
reason reason why no one has been able
to beat it thus far is that with each
level the difficulty of the game
increases relatively minor challenges in
the first few levels give way to
extremely difficult life-threatening
scenarios as the player progresses these
levels broadly follow the same pattern
each time but individual levels often
contain an element of Randomness for
example level one that Sally and John
played contained rats but other tests
have shown subjects being swarmed by
insects and and spiders often coinciding
with established phobias that the
subject has reported prior to The
Experiment 2 hours later John and Sally
were running low on ammo with both
couches pushed against the door to the
lounge they both hunkered down behind
the TV loading the remains of their
shells into the shotguns from out in the
hallway they could hear the heavy
footsteps of more animals rushing
towards them when the pounding on their
door had first started they assumed it
had been their neighbor coming up to
complain of about their screaming and
running around in the previous levels
John had been so deep in thought trying
to work out what their cover story could
be that when he opened the door and saw
an adult grizzly bear standing on its
hind legs in front of him it had taken
him almost too long to react sprinting
back into the lounge he found his wife
already loading rounds into the shotgun
that had suddenly appeared on the floor
in front of her with a grim expression
on her face she seemed to have accepted
their new reality that this was a game
game they were going to have to fight
their way through but with every bear
they shot as it tried to push its way
into their Lounge two more had appeared
just minutes later while they had been
conservative with their ammo aiming for
the heads and not taking any risks the
pair was starting to run dangerously low
was there an objective they were missing
were they supposed to have done
something to progress through the level
Sally mashed a couple buttons on the NES
controller and then some text appeared
on the red screen OBC Ive survive four
Bears appeared in the doorway and pushed
hard against the couch it slid out of
the way and they charged into the room
Sally and John desperately took down the
first two of them but the dreaded click
of the triggers told them they had
nothing left closing their eyes and
bracing themselves for the worst the
pounding of heavy paws on their vinyl
floor suddenly stopped the Bears had
disappeared level three complete well
whatever's next can't be worse than that
surely but it was they managed to hold
out in their apartment until Level 9 but
then the windows behind their heads
smashed into a thousand shards as a
black booted SWAT team swung into the
room with barely any time to react Sally
and John pushed their way out of the
apartment and braced themselves down to
their car slamming both doors closed
they took off racing towards the highway
as the SWAT vehicles pursued them 3
hours later the couple was running low
on gas swerving their way along the
interstate their eyes on the mirrors
constantly the pair was pretty certain
they' managed to lose their as salance
slowing their car to the speed limit
they gently weave their way through the
traffic towards the nearest gas station
trying their best not to look suspicious
the two of them went inside Keen to
stock up on supplies who knew how long
this game would go on for they had
already been active for hours and were
exhausted with the SWAT team hopefully
long behind them now the adrenaline rush
was starting to wear off and the reality
of this situation was starting to set in
hopefully there were just 10 levels and
they only had one to go with the sinking
feeling in their chests each one of them
realized it was more than likely to be
100 definitely time to stock up on some
supplies they were barely Halfway Around
the gas station when the words level 9
complete flashed in the sky above them
both John and Sally froze where they
were and stared at each other over the
aisles a blue flash started past them
outside the windows that again going the
other way Sally ran over to the counter
and banged on the glass lock the door
lock the door but the teenager just
looked at her in confusion and now it
was Sally's turn to look around and see
her husband staring in horror on the
other side of the glass standing between
two gas pumps was
Sonic.exe with haunting red eyes rows
and rows of sharp teeth and blood
dripping from his mouth the Hedgehog
stared intently Sally pointed pointed
out the window and turned to the
teenager yelling but the girl took a
step back looking scared of her the girl
couldn't see it she couldn't see Sonic
for all these challenges all the things
they'd been fighting was it just in her
head but there was no time to worry
about that Sally ran towards the door to
the back of the shop hearing the
footsteps of her husband running after
her she kicked open the fire exit but
froze immediately Sonic.exe was standing
there in front of her smiling it was
toying with with them they needed to run
to get out of here as quickly as
possible but how could they outrun Sonic
hey Sonic John yelled from behind her
you hungry he pushed Sally out of the
way and threw a handful of chili dogs
out into the forest hearing hungry Sonic
spun around and chased after his
favorite food as quickly as possible
that had only bought them a few moments
of time but maybe that was all that they
would get Sally and John ran back
through the convenience store and out
the front they couldn't run but they
they could at least try to hide a semi-
TR had a slam on the brakes as the pair
of them ran across the interstate
without a choice of running anywhere
else all they could do was D into the
woods on the other side and hope that
Sonic had a bad sense of smell but as
they ran through the woods they could
hear an ominous voice echoing behind
them got to go fast got to go faster
than that Sally found a tree and dived
into cover just at the right moment her
husband wasn't so lucky there was a
flash of blue and a horrible crunching
sound before his body hit the ground
Sonic.exe was on top of him in a
heartbeat rows of sharp teeth nashing
Sally clasped both hands over her face
trying desperately to block out the
smell and trap her nervous breathing she
couldn't bring herself to look every
bone in her body wanted to take off
running through the forest out onto the
road to try and find some help but there
was nothing she could do she could never
outrun that thing it was too fast too
Savage even if she could convince
someone on the highway to pull over and
help her it would just tell her she was
going crazy maybe she was then the smell
of her husband's body drifted over to
her on the Wind as the crunching sound
of inhuman Jaws filled her ears new
tears flowed then silence she couldn't
hear anything not even a whisper in the
trees had she done it had she survived
then a red sneaker stepped out from
behind the tree and Sally stared into
the eyes of the blood splattered
deranged Hedgehog Sally blinked and it
was gone level 10 complete the open
Forest stretched out in front of her
without a moment to catch her breath
Sally took off running into the country
on her own whatever was coming next she
had to be ready for it the Shinobi
crouched low on the pagota roof and
listened to the night air up here in the
mountains away from the hustle and
bustle of the markets in town it was
almost silent just the distant rattle of
shutters somewhere behind him the
mountain Shrine was tucked out of sight
so far into the countryside that no one
would stumble onto it by accident no one
would come here without a reason the
Shinobi knew the face of his Target a
warlord turned politician with more
blood on his hands than the Assassin
sent to kill him by the burning glow of
the night sky the Shinobi could see the
man kneeling at the Shrine the path was
made up of small stones so he'd have to
drop onto the grass and creep around the
pond to approach his Target no guards no
one else was there at all this was the
spot where the man came to pray when he
was struggling to sleep perhaps trying
to atone for the lives he'd taken
perhaps he didn't care at all the ninja
drew the blade in total silence and
timed us Dro to the ground with a
rattling noise in the distance with each
dainty step he closed the distance to
his Target readying the blade over his
head it was done in a moment the man was
dead before his body hit the ground he
likely didn't even notice as the steel
had severed the nerves running down his
spinal cord so Shard was the blade that
had slid through his bones like a fish
through water raising the blade to his
eyes the Shinobi cleaned it quickly if
he was seen with blood on his sword he
would immediately be implicated not that
he was ever seen but precautions like
this were what kept him out of sight for
all these years when you lived in The
Valley Of Ashes the burial grounds for
countless Wars you had to become a
shadow become one of the ancient Spirits
haunting the woods but as he wiped the
red from the steel he caught a flash of
light in the reflection an orange glow
marking a jagged line across the metal
that's strange Sunset was several hours
ago come to think of it why was there
there an orange glow in the sky he
snapped his neck around to see the fires
through the gates into the pagot garden
down by the Ocean's Edge at the foot of
the mountains was the city where he had
always lived and it was on fire leaping
up onto the walls he stood up straight
surveying the horror scene taking place
before him thick plumes of smoke
billowed up into the night sky so dense
and large that it seemed to become the
Blackness of the night it was hard to
make out much of what was going on down
there the Shinobi looked everywhere to
try to see the invading army or the
riers but there were none just people
running in all directions like ants out
of a flooding Nest but there moving in
amongst the smoke were other shapes
impossibly tall lumbering around like
people people that towered over the
houses that had to Crane down to the
ground to scoop up the poor civilians
who were running this way and that the
Shinobi stood there terrified as he
realized realized that the rattling
sound he'd been hearing all night wasn't
from any shutters at all he could do
nothing but watch as the trees in front
of him trembled and buckled in all
directions as a hulking shadowy figure
lumbered towards him the Imperial
Japanese anomis matters examination
agency or the
ajaa was a Japanese agency responsible
for tracking a number of mysterious and
often dangerous artifacts creatures and
anomalies prior to the second world war
in 194 5 the AA was shut down and
absorbed into the SCP Foundation all of
these data historic records and
anomalies were all transferred over into
the foundation's control reasons for
this were partially political and
partially in the interest of world peace
the formation of the mmea was influenced
heavily by Japan's ties with Germany in
the first half of the 20th century the
Imperial German anomalous matters
examination agency was the blueprint for
their Japanese equivalent however with
increasing militarism in Japan
throughout the 20th century the mmea
became increasingly obsessed with trying
to harness their anomalous discoveries
in the interests of military power their
goal became the establishment of a
yo-kai battalion powerful enough to
establish them as one of if not the
world's greatest superpower following
the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
Japan surrendered in the second world
war and agreed to dissolve its military
including the Aja MEA that left the
foundation with the task of picking up
the threads left behind and trying to
come up with new ways of securing
containing and protecting some of
Japan's most deadly scps few more deadly
and evasive than the entities that were
too much even for the yo-kai Battalion
SCP
2863 in 1946 cleanup operations were in
full effect trying to deal with the
Fallout from the atomic bomb dropped on
Nagasaki Crews dressed in leadline suits
worked Around the Clock burying
radioactive material and trying to
remove as much contaminated debris as
possible rebuilding the city was still a
long way off at various points the wind
would kick up and carry the dust Left
Behind into the air creating a dangerous
radioactive Haze Crews continued to work
through such conditions as the
understanding of Airborne contamination
was still in its infancy wanabi Goro was
one such worker Midway through a night
shift and clasping a damp rag to his
mouth he pushed on through the dust
clearing out building after building
they had spent the morning carrying
corpses out of an unidentifiable
building the corpses themselves were
pretty much worn away too just skeletons
really charred by the blast from months
before as Goro staggered along the
street he kept feeling like he was
imagining things the long hours and
traumatic conditions were enough to make
him see all kinds of things in his
dreams but he kept feeling like his
dreams were starting to creep into the
real world Shadows kept moving through
the haze all around him taller than
buildings staggering around as if they
were drunk they had been appearing all
night just out of sight but always close
by he stopped and leaned against what
was left of a brick wall there was one
of his hallucinations now just up ahead
of him the husks of buildings on either
side of him were about as tall as their
knees it must have been 30 m tall at
least but its legs were strange there
seemed to be a gap in the middle of each
of them they were skinny no skeletal the
skeleton's foot crushed a car right in
front of him the crunch of metal was
loud enough to snap Goro out of his
stuper this wasn't a hallucination
hallucinations can't crush cars with a
Yelp he tumbled backwards staring up
into the haze of dust he saw the shape
of a pelvis above it what must have been
a rib cage the size of his house but the
creature disappeared into the darkness
and the Dust if it was too tall for him
to see its face maybe it was too tall to
see him on the ground as well the
skeleton stopped standing directly over
him for a second he thought that maybe
he'd be okay but then with a great
rattling Rumble the monster hunched down
low and the enormous skull appeared out
of the haze flying right towards him he
managed to dodge its nashing teeth but
it caught his foot sending him rolling
through the radioactive dirt Goro didn't
give himself a moment to recover though
he took off running as fast as he could
hearing the rattling sound terrifyingly
close behind his back you will be
pleased to know that wanabi Goro
survived this incident with only minor
injuries he managed to navigate his way
to the nearest police station where SCP
agents already familiar with the entity
he had encountered took control of the
situation the so-called starving
skeletons had been roaming the bomb
sites for several weeks by that point it
was the foundation's first exposure to
one of the oldest known entities that
the AA had been studying for years to
date 206 separate instances of SCP 2863
have been officially recorded however
the myth of the gasha doru had been
circulating in various parts of Japan
since the 10th Century at least giant
skeletons were said to haunt the sights
of particularly deadly battles hunting
by night and feeding on the blood of
their human victims these myths tally up
with what the foundation currently knows
about these entities instances of SCP
2863 only appear after Sunset and will
lose all Corporal reality when exposed
to sunlight in the morning or any light
source over 1.1 Lux to give you some
reference for that Moonlight typically
Falls between .25 and one Lux a typical
room with the light on will be 100 or
even 1,000 times brighter as you can
imagine this has made them virtually
impossible to contain as they manifest
and unmanifest outside of controllable
conditions they seem to have continuous
existence in some way however as
previously neutralized instances can and
will reappear later on in folklore the
gashadokuro are spirits that take
control of skeletons some hesitant
researchers have posited that perhaps
the instances that dematerialize are
returning to their Spirit form little is
understood about what that means in
practice what's more this SCP cannot be
photographed all attempts to capture of
them on film or digital cameras have
failed including video tests it is
theorized that there is a link between
them not appearing on camera and their
disappearance when exposed to light
again the link between them is still
mostly unknown due to a steady increase
in urban development in Japan and
ongoing peace in the region appearances
of this SCP are growing increasingly
rare while this marks a positive change
for the people of Japan it makes it even
more difficult to study this SCP and
learn learn how to prevent it in the
future the most recent fatality to occur
at the Bony hands of SCP 2863 happened
in 2008 and it was part of a foundation
experiment While most of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki had been redeveloped into
bustling metropolitan areas the
outskirts of each City particularly
several Parks saw occasional instances
of SCP 2863 appearing at night as such
the SCP Foundation conducted a series of
experiments under cover of Nightfall
releasing d-class Personnel into a park
in Hiroshima to observe how the scps
hunted humans their enormous height
towering at over 30 m gave them a huge
Advantage being able to chase people
down with little difficulty another
notable thing about them is just how
quietly they move there is a gentle
rattling sound that follows them around
but aside from that they are very lightf
footed and difficult to detect until
they are right on top of you this isn't
helped by the fact that they hunt at
night as a result they are remarkably
quick at catching their prey once they
have snatched their victims up in their
skeletal fingers they perform the same
eating ritual every time they eat the
person and consume their blood initially
confused by this finding the foundation
was unsure where the blood was going as
the skeletons had no obvious digestive
system after the release of several more
d-class Personnel into the park they
still weren't certain but they believed
that the SCP instances were absorbing
the blood into their bones in some way
further testing was requested but denied
due to the sheer number of d-class
fatalities in the area they were
starting to run out and would have to
ship more of them across to Japan which
was just a bit inconvenient for everyone
involved as the outskirts of those
cities have been urbanized the instances
of SCP 2863 have reduced to the point
that a smaller contingent of agents and
researchers are now left in place the
light pollution from these areas is
enough to prevent them from being able
to manifest in the first place for the
most part only on the rare occasion of
power outages have mobile task force 03
been deployed whilst researching this
SCP the foundation came across an
account from a Shinobi in the 1700s it
was rare to find any kind of written
document from a ninja for obvious
reasons but the account discovered
painted a harrowing picture of just how
much damage these yo-kai could inflict
upon a city the nameless Shinobi first
encountered SCP 2863 while assassinating
an named Target in the mountains above
his fishing Town looking down on the
fires below him he saw human shapes
walking through the smoke dwarfing the
buildings they move between before an
instance charge through the trees
straight at him diving out of the way
the Shinobi quickly melted into the
Shadows both man and Demon hunted one
another throughout the night he managed
to climb onto its spine and inflict what
he was certain would be a killing blow
to the skeleton only for his blade to
bounce right off the bone caught and
vulnerable for the first time in his
life the Shinobi was helpless as the
spirit threw him from its back into the
courtyard and charged at him it was only
the Hem of the Ninja's sleeve Catching
Fire from a candle that saved him just
as the skeleton was about to bite down
on his head the light flared and the SCP
disappeared entirely for a long while
the man lay in the courtyard pondering
his actions he should have died that
night yet he survived getting slowly to
his feet the man now knew knew what his
Destiny was a monster that strikes from
the Shadows scared of the light he and
aasad doru were not so different
understanding his Target was the first
step to defeating them snatching up a
lantern from the ground the Shinobi
descended the mountain into the wreckage
of his hometown and defended his people
by night he would emerge hunting down
the gashadokuro under the cover of
Darkness banishing them with the light
hidden under a dark sheet the man fought
night after night narrowly risking death
to to save his people from the onslaught
of the evil spirit a small plaque was
installed by the AA shortly before the
foundation took over the management of
the SCP it was installed at the foot of
an old pagota just outside a small
fishing Village on it was a simple Haiku
walking in Shadow in the midst of our
demons we will find the light the diver
screams A Silent Scream as the giant
Squid's beak digs into his skin it's
many grasping tentacles grabbing him and
holding him in place nearby his fellow
divers are driven half mad with Terror
as they see mysterious figures floating
towards them through the MC and strange
Russian voices speaking in their heads
nobody can help them they're down too
deep too consumed by the darkness and
the pressure of the sea they're now at
the mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government government conducting the
world's first atomic weapons test and
the Soviet Union responding in kind with
nuclear testing of their own the two
Powers entered an arms race fueled by
rivalry and a thirst to prove their
strength on the world stage What
followed were Decades of Staggering
technological advancements as each
Nation tried to outdo and intimidate the
other the Soviet Union crossed into the
cold reaches of outer space deploying
the satellite Sputnik the United States
responded with the founding of NASA
tensions reached a fever pitch during
the Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962 as
United States citizens feared they were
teetering on the brink of nuclear war in
July of 1968 the Soviet Union the United
Kingdom and the United States came
together to sign the treaty on the
nonproliferation of nuclear weapons
agreeing to abandon their pursuit of
increasing nuclear power and turn their
focus to disarmament but several months
before the treaty was signed the Soviet
Soviet government was dealing in
Weaponry far more dangerous than nuclear
missiles something the other world
powers knew nothing about these deadly
secrets were hidden aboard a submarine
known as SCP 741 SCP 741 is the
underwater wreckage of a Soviet
submarine that sank in March of 1968 and
came into the custody of the SCP
Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uclid or
ker class anomaly in theack at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hole was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seem to have left something behind
whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a man Expedition into
the waters around the wreckage described
in incident report 1741 D divers a26
through a30 embarked from the Icebreaker
yamal into the waters below with the
intention of studying the potential
anomalous activity surrounding the
wreckage as the group of divers
approached the submarine they could feel
the shift in the water around them the
oppressive feeling of of abnormally
increasing pressure bearing down and
threatening to crush them if their
specialized diving equipment were to
fail they knew that that would be it and
the command would have to come and fish
their corpses out of the water or even
worse they would vanish entirely meeting
the same mysterious fate as the crew of
that doomed submarine but they couldn't
fix it on that they had a job to do at
first glance the wreckage appeared
undisturbed unchanged since the previous
inspection still they needed to take a
closer look to be sure as the team got
closer to the vessel a30 was startled by
the sight of movement from within the
wreckage spotting motion through one of
the holes in the structure as something
passed by he pointed it out to his
colleagues but they dismissed it as
likely a giant isopod or spider crab
which were crawling all over the
surrounding area a30 laughed off his
jumpiness agreed that they were probably
right and continued the exploration as
planned control authorized the divers to
Pro proed to the next step and a29
activated sonar and lights moving toward
the starboard side breach there a faint
glowing caught his eye the glow
resembled that of radioactive material
but when the team checked the radiation
levels in the area they remained stable
whatever the source of the glow was it
wasn't radioactive at this point his
Neutron counter began to register
something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
vili yini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerge from the darkness
it was only an outline the suggestion of
a silhouette but the shape was
undeniably familiar it looked like a
person the other divers quickly noted
the operation to and began to panic some
checked their nitrogen levels believing
it to be some sort of nitrogen Narcosis
While others pointed out that they
couldn't all be suffering from nitrogen
Narcosis at the same time the unknown
voice continued speaking saying help me
it is getting hard to breathe the divers
debated what to do next questioning
whether what they were seeing was even
real when all at once the humanoid
figure vanished from sight the divers
attempted to shake off the startling
encounter and they resumed their duties
the investigation proceeding as normal
after a few moments of uneventful work
another Interruption presented itself in
the form of a 5 m long squid swimming
around the wreckage its presence
startled the divers at first
particularly those closest to the animal
but the others encouraged them to ignore
it citing the fact that there are no
records of these squid attacking humans
so they did continuing their work as the
squids circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waters there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis extremely
difficult as well threatening the safety
of any divers in the vicinity of the
rack the few records that the foundation
has managed to obtain from the Russian
and US governments indicate that the
submarine was being used to transport
some sort of secret cargo though the
specifics of this cargo are still
unknown there is reason to believe that
it differed from any type of nuclear or
chemical Weaponry on a date redacted
from official files the scps basti was
patrolling the area around SCP 741 when
its sonar detected some unknown entity
approaching SCP 741 from the south at a
pace of 46 knots the crew compared the
acoustic signature of the contact with
known submarines and Torpedoes but could
not find a match the bisti attempted to
reach the contact via sonab buy drops
and active sonar pings but it did not
respond when the contact crossed into
the total underwater exclusion Zone it
became classified as hostile at that
point the sonar recorded sounds of an
undersee missile launch and basti resp
responded with the utmost urgency the
ship broke away from its original area
and fired a type 53 torpedo at the
underwater threat 15 seconds after the
bisti launched its torpedo missiles of
an unidentified configuration were seen
breaking the water flying at a height of
1.8 m and a velocity of .92 Mach the
missiles did not emit any detectable
radar nor did they respond to any launch
chaff or flares from the basti both of
the missiles were engaged by bti's 3K
and5 kinsol surfac to- aair missiles and
cachan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 M and 210 M from
Impact respectively after the missiles
were neutralized the Hostile vessel
could be heard engaging in evasive
maneuvers at this point there were four
closely spaced explosions and the sound
of a submarine disintegrating the
identity of the attacker as well as its
intention toward SCP 741 have not yet
been determined the incident resulted in
the foundation research team suggesting
an expansion of the acoustic sensor net
as well as additional Patrol and defense
assets placed in the area additionally
they advised an acquisition of underc
retaliatory capability the incident was
classified incident 1741 DC the sonar
recordings from the scps bisti during
incident 1741 DC were taken for further
analysis by the research team the
indepth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known forms of propulsion
including Magneto hydrodynamic Drive
currently the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery and it has
not been attributed to any particular
government or organization following the
incident involving the scps bisti an
American intelligence agent reached out
to the foundation offering further
insight into the secretive government
programs looking into SCP 741 he agreed
to sit for an interview with a
foundation researcher assigned to the
project on the condition that his
identity remain detected the SCP
researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crewmen re
Just Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes and a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand load
in this thing just no bodies left when I
first looked into all this I had no clue
what the hell had gone on down there but
I started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts at bio preparent as spies
wind up owing each other favors after a
while and they denied it vly not your
usual cover up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted
know part of it sound like he was going
to puke when I mentioned redacted doctor
do you have any idea what it takes to
make a bioweapons researcher sick now
that wasn't what really bugged me though
what really kept me awake at night was
the KGB file that fell into our hands
they mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the US of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nuk and even once I did they still
didn't even think this was worthy of
action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too Lan and you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any movement of SCP 741 is grounds for
an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets SCP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left alone down
there at the bottom of the sea now go
check out SCP 2316 the bodies in the
water and SCP 054 water nymph for more